two Hello everybody welcome to this
beautiful Wednesday June 14th it is an
early episode
yes and actually we plan on I'll be
doing my best actually uh despite our
historical uh trend of doing terrible
shows that I do believe today should be
good I think it'll be good don't over
promise today's episode sponsored by
expressvpn thank you
the reason that we're starting early
today is because
um Pearl Davis just pearly things that
she's known on the internet
will be calling in today to have a
civil and lovely discussion uh with me
and she's in the UK so uh this was the
best kind of compromise we could put
together time wise and it's I appreciate
her
um you know making the effort at least
to give us a reasonable time to get on
the call so
that's gonna be happening like
in 10 minutes yeah in just a few minutes
yeah at 11. and um
yes and so I look forward to that uh
just a few quick announcements with the
time I've got the subreddit is back up
we're back people we're back baby
what happened
why is this sad music I thought it was
happy
Vice Tucker here with zombie eyes
we're so back
honestly I missed it I did too I was
born where's the subway Zach
Zach is oh come on Doc it's okay
Zack it's okay we all okay he's having a
hard morning
oh wow
we'll get through this together we are a
family his Baba's in the microwave it'll
be out his papa you know they they all
turn on us at times Zach but uh we'll
get through this together
yeah well appreciate that I got we got
you everybody be nice to Zach today on
the subreddit please
a B on the other hand I'm just kidding
nah I missed it I did too I did I did
yeah there's just there's a lot going on
there let's be real those cheeky
bastards
oh do me a favor and hit that new Trump
sound bite that just dropped
they did everything right and they
indicted me I did everything right and
they indicted me
it's so legendary indicted me did
everything right and they indicted me I
did everything right and they indicted
me I walked in and everyone was uh we're
just screaming
pirate Trump he sounds like a pirate
sounds like a pirate someone give that
man a hook walk the plank directed
my ship a great storm This Way Comes A
Stormy Daniels it indicted me I plunder
those documents fair and square by the
pirate code
they buried me treasure on Epstein's
Island okay all right all right
yeah so uh let's see uh a quick uh shout
out I guess to uh the brick Chef that
looks great the brick Chef that's when
you take a step back this is the dude
who makes all these really beautiful
custom Lego pieces right yeah to point
out it's this is Lego because I was
unclear at first just looking at the
front Lego bits yeah these are all Lego
bits if you turn around you can see the
entire thing's Lego he's got a huge uh
Tick Tock following
um yo shout out um it has a celeb in
your world hanza yeah his name's Ethan
so uh oh what a what a guy
what a guy I know it is but yeah he he's
got a really fun Lego Tick Tock so a
huge shout out to him the Lego Chef
thank you bro
um
she's in the lobby great so here's what
I'm gonna do I'm just going to thank our
sponsor
expressvpn and then I'm just gonna get
right into it with pearl and uh
I look forward to that so let me thank
our one sponsor real fast uh expressvp
expressvpn Express
using the internet without expressvpn is
like passing a note in class and having
the teacher read it aloud to everybody
oh golly
cringe mode
and it's like is it Mrs Miss hot and she
has to read that
um
bad times
yeah why does everyone need a VPN that's
a good question
internet service providers know every
single website you visit and isps can
sell this information at ad companies
and Tech Giants who then use your data
to Target you excuse me
what
F that bro why should you use flavors
all different all different security
threats
why use expressvpn well let's see
expressvpn reroutes your network data
through a secure encrypted tunnel so
your ISP cannot see or sell any of your
online activity Stick it to the Man
super simple to use fire it up
click the one button in the app
and bada bing bada boom Bob's your uncle
rated number one by CNET and tech radar
expressvpn is widely known
to be the the best one the premier one
you know it works on phones laptops and
even you can put it on your router so
that everybody on the Wi-Fi is protected
I like expressvpn I mean listen having a
VPN is pretty useful if you need to
if you're using a service or
yeah and you needed to think that you're
connecting from a different geolocation
it can be very useful if you're on
streaming services or websites that are
only accessible to certain countries
like if England or Japan or whatever
or France
um use the VPN to to get access to that
content like Netflix UK Netflix Japan
has got all different content super
awesome
uh yeah it works uh so
yeah I love it yeah it works it's just
it works and it's the best one and it's
the best one in the game and they got a
great offer here check this out protect
your online privacy by visiting
expressvpn.com H3 today that's exp r e s
s
vpn.com H3 and you'll get an extra three
months for free
that's right three months for free at
expressvpn.com H3 thank you to our
lovely sponsor please consider
supporting them if uh
if you're in the market for a VPN thank
you all right so thank you
all right so um yeah let's should we
Philly be this
and just jump right into it
let's what should we what
yeah you know what let's just jump right
into it let's just jump right into it
yeah no let's do it yeah I don't want to
keep her waiting okay all right stand by
let her in
uh one second one second one second
all right
so we are she's in the lobby we're just
connecting her oh there she I could see
her great she's
what's happening I don't know was it me
yeah
oh there's just crazy uh audio feedback
but your camera feed looks great
okay can you hear me okay now yes I can
hear you all good okay okay yeah we
fixed it uh Hi how are you your feed
looks good you sound good thank you
um I'm good how are you
I'm good thank you for calling in
obviously I saw your Tweet
is this a trap or a good faith uh
conversation
I wasn't sure which
well yeah I think I this is a good faith
conversation I mean what would you
consider to be a trap
um
it's kind of like when you walk into an
interview and it's like they're not
trying to have a conversation they're
just trying to like paint you out to be
a certain way I would say sure that
would be like a bad faith when they go
in there with an agenda and they're not
really open to
hearing your thoughts
well certainly I hope for it to be a
challenging conversation but I I hope
that you'll find it to be in good faith
I mean you know a little bit about me
I'm assuming so you kind of know what
smile like
my
my positions on a lot of things but uh I
I do look forward to speaking with you
and I thank you by the way for
accommodating us I know you're in the UK
so I thank you for making the time and
coming out here at a weird hour
yeah I know I used to
um I used to watch you like last year
actually a good amount
like a year or two ago maybe what is oh
like as a fan or as a as like a hate
watch
no I I don't know if it's like awkward
to talk about
um like like Trisha but I used to watch
like the show you guys did together oh
yeah no you can't no you can well thank
you that's nice to hear yeah yeah I know
I know it like didn't work out but I I
actually thought that was really good
content oh like uh you guys did the um
like the bus tour I thought that was so
funny oh thank you that's nice we
actually worked really hard on that all
these guys the bus tour is why for
enemies fell apart so um at least you
enjoyed it oh yeah per segment
well I don't know which guy
it's so long ago it's ancient history I
remember she was upset that it wasn't it
didn't go the way that she was hoping
that it was oh she thought we shot it
unprofessionally yeah but uh but Pearl
liked it so there you go yeah okay
well anyway
um I guess let's just jump right into it
I want to just I don't know how many of
my audience I'm sure a lot do but I kind
of want to just intro introduce you
you've become really successful the past
year or two
kind of uh
you're you're friends with fresh and fit
right those those guys are your dogs so
to speak
uh and you kind of are sympathetic to
their kind of views but you've made a
name for yourself just um on Tick Tock
and on YouTube
so let me just ask you generally like
what kind of messages
are you sharing on your platform what
kind of important messages is it that
you find yourself are about
um I believe in family so I think that
we should have policies that push family
um I think that feminism overall was a
bad thing I think
um
that we should be
I think women are happier when we have
you know a family and kids over a career
in the long run
um
yeah yeah sorry I'm a little nervous
it's okay yeah so it's more like yeah
traditional you you you
want people to kind of follow more a
more traditional path
in terms of family and gender and all
that kind of stuff
yeah well and you just see the negative
um like outcomes a society have when
like families fall apart right and it's
especially hard on the children like you
see
you know
um you know more you're more the kids
are more likely to go to to prison the
more likely to drop out of school
they're more likely
um
to
you know be in mental health
institutions so you just see like all of
the problems that come with so you know
single mother home so I just think it's
important that we push policies that
push family
so how do you push a policy that
promotes family like in what way can you
force a family to stay together or
encourage it in a sense
um well I think you first have to get
rid of incentives that incentivize like
women to leave families so
um like you know for example child
support alimony I'm not really a fan of
those
child support so if so if a um
if there's a divorce
let's say I think we should ban divorce
too yeah I think that should be banned
yes okay well that's a little bit silly
you have to acknowledge that right
no so so Banning divorce means that when
you decide to get married you are you
are not allowed by the government to
leave your significant other in any
situation
yeah
I just think that if you want to leave
you just shouldn't get married
so that's just my opinion right but like
in the real world that kind of
simulation you know there's there's like
exceptions to this but I would just say
in general for most cases you know we
could talk about exceptions but like the
rule well the exceptions are the
important part because I've heard you
say that a lot when you're talking about
things you say oh you want to talk about
exceptions but the exceptions is the
important part because those are the
people that are that are going to be
affected I mean exceptions are going to
be a large part of of uh divorces as you
say I mean you're talking about like you
know 25 maybe or more because if you're
saying you're not allowed to get
divorced so we're talking about like
what if the relationship is physically
abusive
yeah um I think if it's physically see
the this is the problem though all right
if it's one-sided physically abusive
okay
fine divorce we can allow divorce for
those exceptions but like I've even
talked to people that work at like abuse
centers and they say that the majority
of abuse is mutual so it's not just one
side's hitting the hitting the other
it's like Mutual so surely that's not
everything I think
yeah I know and it's not healthier
either
I just think that the goal should be to
keep families together and that the goal
should be to work through it
I you know I think most people agree
with that right because we I think we
all can look at the stats and say family
is important right family is important
nuclear families is important to like
the health of of children growing up in
general I think we can all say that
but when you say something like
divorce should be illegal yeah we got to
kind of suss that out because that's a
pretty uh extreme claim for example
um in 2014
Family Violence was the cause of 25
percent of divorces so I don't think
it's fair to characterize that as some
kind of like super Fringe example of why
people get divorced
well but you also have to look if
there's incentive structures in place
where there's a lot of false accusations
in Family Court
um like and a lot of people don't know
this that family court is actually based
off it's not based off of evidence it's
based off a balance of probabilities and
there are incentive programs that you
get
um like in the UK you get a free lawyer
if you accuse your husband of abuse and
it's less than 10 percent of cases are
actually like followed through with with
the police
sorry I I don't want to move on quite
yet I want to stick on the topic of not
allowing people to divorce so you're
saying that you do want to allow people
to divorce then you don't really believe
that
now I would say ban divorce oh because
you just said you would allow an
exception in the case of abuse
I said one-sided abuse exception sure
okay so how do you prove the one so then
you don't believe in forced Force
except for one-sided abuse okay except
for one-sided abuse and is there going
to be a system to kind of uh how do you
prove that that uh the woman or man I
think yeah I think you have to you have
to press charges in Criminal Court not
family court
so only if your significant other is
tried criminally are you allowed to
leave the relationship
tried and found guilty criminally yes
yes
I want to be with someone forever but I
just say stay out of marriage no because
marriage is supposed to be you know for
better for worse and sickness and health
and for richer or for poor it's not
supposed to be you know when I feel like
leaving and the majority of divorces
nowadays it's just you know when the
girl just feels like leaving that's not
true so and and well you know it's just
not true I've talked to I've talked to
hundreds of women
that doesn't prove it and even if you
look at if you look at uh when no fault
divorce was
initiated in the 80 and
1970 I think it was initiated I mean one
of one of the number one reasons was
Financial differences and irreconcilable
differ and reconcile and yeah and
recklessly yeah I'm sorry I can't talk
um but so so but yeah I just think like
you know
for the people that don't believe in
real because what What is marriage if
you can get divorced over damn near
anything it's not marriage anymore it's
something else well I think the reason
for that historically this uh emphasis
on staying married right
or even before this uh no fault divorce
was an option and it was more difficult
for women to get divorced or men
the uh abuse of power and the risk for
abuse and for people to get stuck in a
horrible relationship situation not just
for them but their kids right I mean
obviously you have seen having your kids
watch their mother get beat up and and
oftentimes it's going to bleed or the
kids get watching their father get beat
up like it goes both ways I've yeah and
I acknowledge that it goes both ways so
both people have a right to
in my opinion get divorced because the
alternative is one of the partners being
stuck and like
do you do you think actually a lethal do
you think that's the majority of cases a
majority of cases of what divorce I'm
divorced 45 25 it's 25 based on
statistics that's not no that's not
what's um in criminal court it's like
less than less than 10
um it actually followed through in
Criminal Court well regardless 10 is
enough don't you think
no I said less than 10 of the abuse
cases of the 25 so that's like
Journal of Family Violence in 2014
founded approximately 25 of divorces in
the United States involved domestic
violence
right but again that's because the woman
says that she was because they're inside
but you're just saying stuff you're just
saying stuff you don't actually know
that to be true no I do how I do like
okay in the UK there's a law that you
get a free lawyer if um
sorry but how does that prove that women
are lying about violence because no
because I'm saying that you can't okay
you can't prove it unless they go to
criminal court because Criminal Court is
based off of evidence where where family
court is based off of a balance of
probability so it means it's more likely
that they did it than didn't do it it's
not innocent until proven guilty
right but they're not going to jail it's
just to let this the abused uh I mean
you could call it jail when you have a
lifetime of not seeing your children
I mean you you could I mean have you
spoken to these men it's like literally
their whole Community thinks they're an
abuser now they they get to see their
kids maybe three days a month if they're
lucky
um a lot of them are yeah sure
yeah there's there's bad outcomes for
sure but on the whole a lot of men a lot
of men zero themselves out during this
they what
um like a lot of men commit suicide yeah
oh that's horrible you know it's
horrible it's like absolutely terrible
like I interview these men that are
going through this uh yeah I'm sure
that's happened but at the same time
you're saying women are lying about
violence and I haven't seen you before
okay I'm saying I'm saying that that you
can't prove it unless you go to criminal
court because family is not a crime
right but they're not going to jail it's
just about the welfare of the kids and
you know I mean the people it's a crime
if you're if you're falsely accusing
someone of abuse
um I'm saying I'm saying there's no you
can't they only prove it in less than 10
percent of cases
okay because Criminal Court is based off
of evidence family court is not so let's
just say less than 10 I'll just give you
the benefit of the doubt on that still
seems like enough
to give people the option to leave and
this idea that women just leave whenever
they want seems a little bit infantile
since because people change right
especially when people get married young
which does happen people change people
uh go through [__] people grow apart a
lot of them a lot of The Men Who end up
being abusive you here are were one way
before they got married and one way
after you get married so I don't think
it's fair to say uh you're just leaving
whenever you want or or you should just
have to stay in this forever wouldn't
you prefer people get married then never
get married like I feel like you would
be disturbed if like only you know five
percent of couples ever got married
mm-hmm
um
um I'd rather people got married and
stayed married right but that wasn't one
of the options
um I I actually don't see a point in
getting married with the way that
marriage is today to be honest
um
yeah because again like what is it the
average marriage is like eight years
so the average marriage is is eight
years and you're done that's not
marriage
um
leaving a marriage
due to domestic violence and not
pursuing criminal charges if so let's
say that a woman's in a marriage and
they have uh no no fault marriage uh
divorce
so let's say she doesn't want to charge
her husband she just wants to leave
amicably okay but in your situation
she's forced to charge him
legally to have a police investigation
charge him for domestic violence
wouldn't that be more damaging to his
reputation
how did he beat the case because again
it's based off of evidence but I mean I
think that why would you want an abusive
guy walking free if he's actually
abusive he should go to jail
um right shouldn't we agree on that
right but it's just not that simple
again because like this is it's just not
that simple abuse cases because
you know and it's not that simple to to
convict people I just I just don't think
that men should be punished without
evidence and I think in Family Court
there it's not based off of evidence
it's based on a balance of probabilities
and so you have a case where men only
like they're stuck seeing their kid like
three days a month when again it's not
based off of evidence like
you know I've interviewed guys where
literally the the wife um and I've seen
the court documents though it's coming
out in my documentary that's coming out
in the fall
um but
the wife
um was plotting
to try to get the guy to hit her right
I'm sure that happens but you know that
and the wife still got custody right but
that that that's not a representative
case again I mean for example
you ask why a mom wouldn't want to try a
parent it's more nuanced right I mean
you need a more in you need a more uh
developed take on that because it's very
traumatic
for the kids in the family to put their
father through
a violence case and especially when the
kids are probably going to have to ask
to testify to talk to the police I mean
I I totally understand why mother or
father wouldn't want to put their family
through that what don't you
I mean I can understand it yeah sure
sure and I mean according to National
statistics on domestic violence okay
there's 10 million men and women
each year that are the victim of
physical abuse
but in your world I have a feeling that
a lot of these people would be trapped
in these marriages
mm-hmm and that's okay
I I sat in one-sided abuse they could
leave yes okay no no okay
um I do think I do think in order to get
custody of your kids if you're gonna
accuse the other side of abuse you
should have to prove it
do you think what what you think is more
harmful to kids uh divorce or physical
abuse
physical abuse okay you passed that one
but you had to think about it for a
second but anyway let's move on from
this no I just I just thought it was
kind of a silly question that was all
but okay that's refreshing
um tell me what does red pilled mean to
you because I've heard you use that
phrase a lot you're part of the red
pilled community
yeah I mean
it's a lot of people I will say a lot of
people have their own definitions of it
so people use it for different things
but I would say it's viewing the world
the way it's supposed to be or like the
way it is not the way you're told it is
so
um
like you know for example a lot of guys
think if they treat a girl nice and give
her flowers that you know she'll
essentially sleep with him
and then a lot of guys find out that's
not true and so then they you know
came together and yeah realized that so
that's just one thing is that true do
people do when do men really believe
that
what do you mean that if you buy flowers
and be nice she'll sleep with you
yeah I think so
yeah I don't think so I don't think
that's real I think that's like a really
odd way to describe dating it's just
like men are nice guys and women
cartoonish like we're talking about real
world stuff and it's just you can't I
mean I just think men don't really
men don't expect like women to reproduce
more with felons than non-felons
like I think that's a surprise
women reproduce more with felons
violence felons yeah
I mean like think about it anyway
what is that what does that mean so so
felons who are procreating have more
kids in general than non-films what does
that stat mean
they have more children with felons than
not it's like I don't remember if it's
violent felons versus non-violent felons
but I just remember violent felons have
more children than non-violent felons
and so there's men who are looking at
that and they're pissed
right I've never heard that stuff
okay
yeah is there a source for that it just
seems kind of an odd stat like what does
it prove felons have more kids than
non-felons well I think the reason the
reasoning is because women want a guy
that can
um like protect her basically a felon
why do you think Ted Bundy had like love
letters oh well that's a whole different
weird phenomenon about women being
interested some weird uh
that's surprising right it is surprising
but I don't think it's any interesting
commentary on the dating scene that that
serial killers get Love Letters from
from freaks you know I mean Richard
Rainier is did too all serial killers do
yeah but the point is it's one like it's
not the same for women it's just man
so what is your point exactly that uh
that what does that prove that felons
have more kids than non-felons
um you know that a lot of times women
pick the Bad Boys you know I mean that's
pretty much it does having more kids
with I mean a guy that's a violent felon
you don't think okay
is there a source for that it's just a
really weird stat I'm just trying to
Grapple with it I can get it I can get
it in a second yeah that would be great
I mean we can try to look for it too I
just want to hear what then I can show
you where I found it okay that's
fantastic
yeah Casey Anthony got love letters
apparently so she was a she was a serial
killer right
oh she killed her daughter not cereal
just just a one so Casey Anthony
murdered her daughter and she was
getting love letters too she got letters
proposing marriage don't you find that
surprising
yeah yeah that is surprising so in a
sense it's not it goes both ways kind of
when you look at it holistically
no I think it's more so for women pick
Violent Men more than men pick violent
women
based on what
um
I think you can just
um I would just say I would guess I
would guess that it's more common with
women
because of that study versus like a
fringe case I would be surprised if
women got the same amount of letters but
you know I could be could be you might
be surprised but do you feel that
sometimes you argue from emotion rather
than like concrete facts I find that
when you talk about and I've watched a
lot of your videos you say stuff
that I don't think has much of a backing
in reality is based on feelings maybe
instead of not emotions but feelings you
say I feel this to be true do you feel
you do that a lot or no
um I try I would say I
I'm a woman so sometimes yeah okay
interesting defense
you know
hold on do you want me to find it or no
sure yeah you I'll I'll give you a
minute that's totally fine
uh but uh okay
so why should I engage with in a
conversation with you at all if you're
if women are just emotional shouldn't I
be talking to a man about this
probably
why do you bother to even have a
platform shouldn't you just concede to a
man
yeah probably you know
so we got to look for a man to replace
you
dank
um
no not not really you don't think okay
but you do think women are more
important okay I I gotta find okay go
ahead I'll give you a minute sorry I
won't okay I'm sorry I'm trying to like
talk to you at the same time
yeah I'll give you a minute there but
it's it's fine too we can move on if
I'll give you a minute but we can we
don't have to get stuck on it
okay
[Music]
it's I mean we can it's fine we can move
on
might be a while
I found it oh go ahead okay perfect
there we go
[Music]
um
what's it called I'll pull it up
yeah
the link he pulls up the study in this
Stream So the link is on here
whose stream is it
um it's a rollout stream
yeah yeah he's great actually I know
you're a fan he seems like a nice guy
yeah he's really nice
um I like his head where
I like when he rocks out where do I
where do I send it to uh send it in the
zoom chat Zoom chat yeah uh or you could
just tell me the name of it and I can
pull it up okay it's in
Rolo tomasi is offensive and vile
it's like seven months ago thank you I
appreciate that we'll look into it so if
women are are so emotional do you think
it's bad faith in terms of an argument
to argue from feelings
and to present feelings as facts
do you think that's a bad faith way to
argue or no
kind of kidding I was like
when
whatever you're asking me earlier you
were like
um
I don't even remember you said something
like do you think you shouldn't have a
platform or like well right well I asked
and you said uh well I'm a woman of
course I'm gonna I asked you do you feel
that you make arguments based on feeling
and you said yes I do because I'm a
woman
oh yeah I was kidding um no I use
no I use facts to back up my arguments
um sometimes I'd say I'm wrong um
sometimes I think something and it's not
correct but I would say most of my
opinions I try to at least have a basis
of fact yes okay
some things
see in reality right I mean like
something
yeah I mean you know you can
like some things you just learn from
interviewing hundreds of people you see
patterns right but sometimes when you
interview people you interviewing
specific people with specific
experiences you're obviously gonna run
into a bias
um no I don't think so think so because
we do Street interviews all the time too
so that's like random people on the
street
okay fair enough so what so there's the
red pilled which are people who see the
world for what it is and then you have
blue pilled people which I'm assuming is
someone like me I don't know I don't put
words in your mouth but uh what does
blue pilled mean
um people that see the world for how
they'd like like it to be I guess okay I
I don't I don't talk a lot much about
I guess like blue pill but yeah okay
fair enough we don't we don't have to
focus in on that
so I've noticed that one of the primary
focuses of your content is kind of the
problems facing men and how there's so
much unfair uh societal pressures or
Norms or expectations on men
um why is it that you're so singularly
focused on the Troubles of men
um
why am I focused on the Troubles of men
that's an interesting way to I guess
phrase my content
um
I I would say I I think it's unfortunate
what happens to men in divorce court so
that's probably why I talk about the
most is I think that men should have
access to their children
that's not what you talk about the most
uh you definitely talk about stuff like
pay Gap myth you talk about men want
younger girls you talk about men are
just doing what's in their nature you
talk about women who have higher body
count are less desirable I haven't I'll
be honest I've talked I've watched a lot
of your stuff and the vast majority is
not about divorce court it's about this
kind of like dating coach stuff
no I wouldn't say I'm a dating coach but
okay well but that realm you know what I
mean like I don't mean you're a dating
coach but like that kind of Realm it
seems that you're super focused on so
what is your interest in that manosphere
maybe that's a better term manosphere
stuff
um
interest I don't know I just thought it
was interesting so that's what we talk
about okay that's fair
um
so what is you say your anti-feminism
feminism was basically a mistake so what
is your problem with feminism let's
start there that's a good point right
um I think that feminism wants equality
when it benefits us and not actual
quality
and that's are you going back to the
beginning of feminism like the whole
history of feminism like if women
suffrage and everything yeah no I don't
you don't [__] with women's suffrage
[Music]
um
you don't think women should get the
right to vote
no no I don't
okay so are you serious are you kidding
no I'm serious okay so women shouldn't
get they shouldn't have the right to
vote
yeah wow
um because men are signed up for
Selective Service so they're fined three
hundred thousand dollars um if they're
not if they don't sign up for Selective
Service when they're 18. do you think
women should be drafted into the army
okay if we want the same rights it comes
with the same responsibility do you
think women should be drafted into the
army
no okay so then there's a paradise
that's my point I'm saying like let's
make it fair you don't believe well
listen this is your perfect one okay I'm
saying I'm saying I'm saying that if we
are going to vote have the same cost
which is that
men are put into Selective Service and
women are not and if I had to pick
between the two
then I would give up the right to vote
instead of sign up for Selective Service
okay so you're saying
women should only get the right to vote
if they sign up for Selective Service
but at the same time you're saying women
should not serve in the military so in
your world women are just going to be
disenfranchised because they're not
going to be able to sign there you they
shouldn't serve in the military because
they're not as good Fighters no no I'm
saying if I I'm saying for me personally
I would not want to sign up for
Selective Service if I had to pick so
yeah I would give that up you think
women should be given the choice if they
want to do selective service or not
I think if we're going to vote we should
have no choice like the men do so women
should be drafted mandatory into
Selective Service you believe
no that's okay but don't you see the
Lord
I said no I said I said if feminist like
if feminists want the right to vote
right then it should come with the draft
it should come I mean it's not called
the draft anymore it's called Selective
Service personally
in Pearl's world I do not want to be
drafted I do not want to be in Selective
Service
in general in terms of policy because
obviously I think it's safe to say women
in general want the right to vote right
and so
then by your logic women need to be
entered into Selective Service
mm-hmm right but you don't think that
should happen or you think that's okay
yeah I'd rather not not you I mean in
general the the women because women want
to vote so how do we resolve this issue
do they get drafted like man I mean I
think it's I mean I think it's unlikely
that women will ever have the right to
vote taken away so I guess moving
forward maybe net taxpayers potentially
you could do but
yeah that's a whole other conversation
but no I think we're gonna if we're
gonna vote I think that we should
have the same responsibility as the men
and be enlisted in Selective Service
okay okay so you're saying
women should also have to sign up for
Selective Service when they turn 18 like
men yeah yeah okay if you're going to be
equal make it equal okay and for me for
me
I don't want to do that no thank you
I'll keep me out of that okay so you
right I understand that's your
preference but I'm just trying to
understand like the policy that in your
red pill we're doing the red pill we're
seeing the world as it is no no I
wouldn't I wouldn't assign that belief
to like red pill that's not really like
a a red pill belief that's just mine
okay cool yeah I'm just trying to make a
point about so so do you think having
women in the Army would weaken our
military
yes
so then
probably don't draft women into the army
yeah but then take away the vote with it
but did you you're not giving that that
doesn't seem very fair you see what I'm
saying
because you say well you guys are weaker
you guys are gonna weaken our military
so we don't want you in the military but
because you're not in the military you
don't get the right to vote it's a
catch-22 you know what I mean
mm-hmm
so what do we do about that
well I'll tell you what I think we
should do go ahead no no I mean it goes
back to
I just think that you have to have some
skin in the game and so it's like if
we're voting for a commander-in-chief
right that's the person that decides if
we go to war we don't go to war and so
it's easy to
you know again I think that if you're
gonna vote you should have the same
responsibility as the men and women
don't want to do that it's either we're
equal or we're not equal okay just to be
fair if we're really if we're really
equal have the same responsibility but
again it's equality when it benefits us
well but your logic doesn't even make
sense I mean you're talking about first
of all there hasn't even been a draft in
the in the United States in 50 years
right so if there was a draft maybe we
could have this conversation but it just
seems kind of silly if 50 years that
hasn't been a mandatory draft it just
hasn't happened mm-hmm
so
so why is it a big deal I guess about
the selective service because it's a
there's not going to be another draft
you know what I mean there's there's
enough people in the Army uh I don't
think that there's going to be a draft
it's just not going to happen and with
the way technology is going we're going
to have autonomous robot Fighters before
there's a draft you know what I mean so
why does it matter I just don't see the
point with the Selective Service thing I
just think it's again like women want
all the rights without the rest what
other ones if you don't if you don't
think if you don't think that there's
going to be a draft then equally do what
the men do
thousand dollars they don't have the
option they don't even have the option
right now
right so give them the option you know
let's give them the option make it equal
let's put another option there has to be
mandatory for one of you saying like
women want the right to vote but they
don't want to enter in selective service
but it's not an option though how do you
know what all women want
I don't know what all women want so then
why are you saying things that are
generalized all women I'm saying no okay
because I'm looking at the policies that
have been pushed when saying the
policies are not like where where are
the feminists fighting for equality in
this situation like when it yeah I mean
again it's not that relevant but also
the no women in the Army is a kind of an
a micro product of
um patriarchy because women are looked
as that they'd weak in the military as
you pointed out is that possible that
it's been driving that policy and not so
much women
I didn't say women drove that policy I
said they don't try to make it equal
it's only equal when it benefits us
even if nobody's being actually drafted
be yours isn't you know that long of I
mean who's to say you don't know but
okay
in 50 years I mean the last man I mean
like Mom wasn't it
do you do you not do you not think it
should be equal so you think that it
shouldn't be
no I think it's I think what you're
saying is fair but it's not it's not
making any sense like okay sure let's
put women into us into you know
Selective Service fine I'm fine with
that I think it's fine
okay I think everyone should sign up for
it and there's other people there's
other ways that people can support the
military other than being on the front
line right
right
so what other rights do women uh
want you know what I mean that
are are contradictory
um okay women want the right to not be a
mother but men don't have the right to
not be a father
so women women can have a uh which I
know a very state I'm in the UK so I
kind of I forget sometimes the US is
different by state but
um like in the UK abortions free up to
six months but a man can't can't opt out
of Child Support so it's like why does
he have the right to not be a father but
women don't or why do women have the
right to not be mothers but men don't
have the right to not be fathers I don't
think that's fair or equal sorry just to
go back for a sec so feminists actually
do uh they are
they want the draft abolished
so their point is let's not sign up for
the service let's abolish the draft
altogether so they are falling they are
fighting for equality they are against
the draft there should be no draft so
men and women shouldn't be drafted that
is also equality isn't it
oh yeah yeah okay
so you're so you accept so you just you
accept the premise is wrong on that
um I don't I mean it's still not equal
the way it is but yeah what they're
saying it's not equal the way it is sure
and yeah
okay I've never heard him talk about
that but do you listen to a lot of
feminists uh ideology do you read books
do you listen to lectures how do you
listen to a lot of that stuff
so I talk to feminists all the time
right I haven't seen you talk to her
actual scholar once you just talk to
kind of random women
right I mean that's fair to say
right
So when you say you talk to feminists
you may just being like random women off
the street
not like that Scholars that say they're
feminists yeah but it's it the feminism
it's like a
it doesn't count well you said you know
what you said you know what feminists
believe because you talk to a lot of
feminists but I'm talking about like no
I said I've never heard them bring it up
so do you have any interest in talking
to feminist Scholars who are more aware
with like kind of what feminism yeah I
actually yeah I think you know you're
good send them send them to the UK
but you're well they're in the UK
no I actually tried for some but then
they'll be like you're a hateful woman
there's one there's one that's I can't
even remember some blonde chick out here
I can't remember her name but yeah she
didn't want to come on
blondes
no I'm just saying that was her that's
what she looked like I don't know her
name I forgot but like I mean my point
is is like when you just bring a random
girl and they say yeah I'm a feminist
it's kind of like the Stephen Crowder
changed my mind versus like actually
talking to someone who's involved in
like the Scholastics you know the
Academia of what feminism means
historically in modern day and
previously
so the the level of discourse you would
have is is obviously different
[Music]
um
so
um so so feminists are in favor of uh
equality though so I don't know if
that's interesting you or not
mm-hmm
you don't believe me
um I'll take your word
uh you can trust me I'm a man
okay
okay so moving on uh oh yeah we're
talking about um we're talking about
feminism so what other so you're talking
about divorce court sorry I know you
were making a point so let's go back to
that you were saying that
women can decide to terminate a
pregnancy therefore they can choose to
be a mom but men cannot decide that and
they don't get the choice to be the dad
to not be a dad right
so do you think that like
do you do not think that the idea that
the baby obviously the reason for that
right which we both know is that because
the babies inside the woman's body
um
I don't think that matters yeah
so I mean personally personally I'm
pro-life so I don't believe in abortion
at all but again it's the it's the
double standard it's like the women have
a choice but men do not have a choice
sure no I see that there's a there is a
sense to that which is unfair
mm-hmm although there are a lot of
single moms as you pointed out
um
yeah that are on child support you know
not all not all but you know well men
have the choice in the sense that they
can just wear a condom
right yeah
right but women have the choice to go on
birth control
okay women but ultimately women have the
choice to get an abortion women have a
have the choice to
you know take the morning after pill
women have the choice you've like IUD
there's a million pills right but those
are those right those will have to do
with pregnancy but I'm saying if a woman
also can require men to put on condoms
or not put on condoms I'm sorry I say
that again women can also require that
the men that they sleep with wear
condoms right but if it's inherent if
it's inherently
unfair to men
the easy solution is just it kills every
all this discussion is men just put on
condoms when they have sex therefore
that well you can also say women close
your legs like yeah but you're the one
saying that it's unfair for men that's
my point you're saying men I'm saying
women have like 10 choices the men have
but that's just biology no men have the
men have condom or no condom which again
is a choice that both of them make
because the women can require that the
men wear condoms too right
I'm just saying you once the once the
baby is conceived right yeah then the
man has no choice where the woman has a
choice okay so let's just talk about
that then because um
so it's your opinion that if a woman is
pregnant the man should be able to
decide for her to have an abortion
I'm pro-life so I would ban it all
together
um my my point my point is the double
standard where a man
um is legally obligated to pay child
support and will go to jail if he
doesn't but the women has the choice to
not be a mother through abortion
I know you're against abortion but I
just want to know what you what you mean
so let's just say
we're trying to make it uh equal for men
so should men be able to decide for
women to have an abortion if she's
pregnant
um I think that men should be able to
sign off on child support
okay so they so they say hey I don't
want anything to do with this baby yeah
then the woman can decide to have it but
the father will have no obligations yes
and you think that's better for society
no I think I think that's equal that's
more fair
okay so your word you're more interested
in fairness than the the welfare of
society as a whole no if it was up to me
if we wanted to go what's good for
society I I don't think abortion should
be legal no I know I know we're having
that's what I'm saying like I'm saying
if you want to make it fair like I don't
think that's fair that the woman after
she gets pregnant so they both make the
irresponsible decision right because
you'd agree it's irresponsible if it's
an unplanned pregnancy that the woman
you know had sex with a guy without
protection right we'd agree
yes yeah yeah yeah so you would agree
that's equally irresponsible when it
first happens although I guess it by
your logic would be more irresponsible
for the men because he has less choices
but yeah they're both doing something
interesting well you know you know but
yeah they're both irresponsible so my
point is after that happens
women have the choice to not be a mother
but men don't have the choice not to be
a father at least you know um you know
if they don't pay child support they can
go to jail right because that's for the
benefit of the children which is what's
the most important thing yeah but is it
for the benefit of the kid to kill him
like say what dude it's not for the
benefit of the kid like like the woman
can make it what do you mean to kill who
yeah so if we're going to go for the
benefit of the kid like if your argument
is let's do what's best for the benefit
of the kid the benefit of the kid is not
killing the child is right I mean and
for me like I believe I believe it's a
kid right you you might not what's that
have to do with the fairness to the man
I don't understand that I you don't
understand
it's not fair again that men have the
choice that men do not have the choice
understand what you're saying and women
yeah but then okay whatever let's we're
arguing in circles a little bit
um let's talk about abortion then since
you're against abortion
um
I'm assuming your stance is abortion is
should be
off the table in any situation
yes
so if a dad rapes his daughter then she
needs to give birth to that baby
you know that's less than one percent of
cases
because if you're gonna have a
conversation about difficult things
let's talk about the difficult things
this is why the laws exist the laws
exist to protect that little girl I'm
saying let's talk about the most common
thing that's easy but I'm saying
something difficult about this the best
thing but I'm saying we can get to the
difficult things later but it's like why
do you guys because that's the
interesting part I'm telling you the law
is there to protect on those French
cases
why don't we start with the the majority
of it didn't we just do that
you think okay what do you want to say
you don't agree on abortion so like if
men and women have sex
and they're both being irresponsible
then sure I understand you say
abortion's bad because we don't want to
murder babies that's not controversial
that's easy to understand the point of
these laws is to protect the little girl
who's raped by her dad these are the
challenging these are the challenging
issues so this is why I ask you about it
because this is the byproduct of your
position of no abortions are allowed
under any circumstance so if you're
willing to take that position you can't
just dismiss this because you are saying
that this girl who's raped by your dad
should have the baby I just think
I just think we I will hold on I just
think we spend a lot of time arguing
about Fringe cases that are less than
like half a percent those are the
important cases that's right I don't I
don't think those are as important as
the 99.5 percent of cases and so
sometimes I think it's a bit
disingenuous to say here is this extreme
Fringe case that happened and I don't
think that's you don't make a law for
the exception yes you don't you don't
make laws the general law is not for the
exception it's for the rule like why why
it's not an exception what why is that
an exception or I mean exceptions are
important to the law okay do you not
think it's an exception like a 13 year
old girl getting graped by her I don't
know what you can stand here
oh I don't think I don't think grapes is
gonna oh we stay away yeah yeah I don't
know but
do you do you not think that's an
exception
you and by exception but well she was
raped what do you mean by acceptance
right like you think it's common no of
course it's not common okay that's
that's my point like we waste do you
think that it's less important do you
think it's less important because it's
London I think it's more I think it's I
think it's more important to talk about
the 99.5 of abortion that's easy that's
an easy conversation
it's not like I get your position there
yeah
you can write exceptions in the laws
that's why they exist because why should
that girl who's raped by her dad forced
to give birth to that baby because you
don't want to have a conversation about
her
yeah well well I mean I I
will make it
um illegal to be
because again I think you either think
it's a life or you don't
so if you think it's a child you're
never gonna
you're never gonna encourage killing a
child under any exceptions so right
that's the right and that's I guess
where the big difference comes between
uh abortion uh people were for and
against abortion is that that we
disagree on where life begins uh
essentially right right but ultimately
what quality of life do you expect this
shell to have from like a 13 year old
girl who's right by her dad
mm-hmm
it's a lower quality life less valuable
like that's almost saying if you're if
you are in a bad situation your life is
less valuable than someone who isn't
that's kind of a tricky argument
uh not less valuable but I mean if we're
one one should be aborted one shouldn't
so one should be in society one
shouldn't be in society I would say
that's less valuable
well it's more about
you you were talking about fairness you
were interested in the idea of fairness
right instead of the welfare of society
so let's talk about fairness you know
what I mean is it fair to the little
girl that she was forcibly impregnated
by your dad
right but is it fair is it fair to the
child
okay so who's I think that's like we
could we could talk about 13 year old is
a child by the way she's 13. she's a
child yeah and I agree and I think
that's horrible and I think there should
be the death penalty for rapist but
yeah I I'm sorry like I just don't I
don't believe in abortion
um and again to me that like to me I
think that's a child and I just can't
advocate for the murder of a kid I
understand where you come from what
about situations where like 12 of
abortions are related to Health crisis
is where there's a chance the woman
might die or the baby might die or both
um
uh your thoughts on that
I don't know enough about those
situations to really have an opinion on
it um
probably guess that they would likely
both die in those situations so
sometimes that's an exception but I I
don't know enough about that stuff
right well we can use our imagination
just for the hypothetical conversation
where there's 12 I'm telling you there
are 12 of abortions are related to
health crisises so if it's the baby
lives but the mom dies what do you think
should happen in that situation
hmm I don't know
okay
I just the reason I'm putting your feet
to the fire on this is because you think
you says very specifically that abortion
should be outlawed in all situations so
of course I'm testing that
yeah
um I could maybe see an exception for
the life of the mother but I've heard
like I've and I don't want to quote this
because again it's just something I've
heard I've heard it's not as common as
people lead you to believe and like
sometimes those stats are manipulated
but I don't yeah but the commonness the
commonness doesn't really matter it's
more about the I think the exceptions
are interesting I disagree I think
when you say why are we focusing on the
exceptions I think that's a way for you
to try to dismiss difficult questions
I think it's like silly when 99.5
portions are not the exception so
you don't but that doesn't make sense I
mean why don't you care about
the situation of everybody else just
because it's not the because it's the
acceptance I just think you should spend
more time debating the most common thing
so that's you know my opinion okay
very good
um so we talked about uh feminism
the problem with feminism is that women
want equality but they don't really want
equality
they need to sign up for the military
which feminists uh
want to abolish the draft and then we're
talking about Reproductive Rights
um
where the women get all the choice and
the men don't is there any other ones
I'm sorry I was reading something what'd
you say
is there any other examples of them
Reproductive Rights and voting slash
draft
that shows that feminism was a mistake
or that feminists are disingenuous or
something like that
um
I would just say like there's just a
lack the biggest one I would say is
Divorce Court
um 90 women get custody 80 to 90 percent
of the time I think ninety percent of
alimony payments are
are given are awarded to women
what does that have to do with women's
suffrage though you said you criticized
the whole thing going all the way back
to it I thought you asked other double
standards no
well I asked you what's your problem
with feminism
in general we can move on though I have
a I have a good question for you I hear
you talk a lot about the pay Gap right
the pay Gap is a myth
mm-hmm what do you mean by that
oh because women don't do the dangerous
jobs in society so like I just think the
pay Gap the majority of the time the
majority
is women making an excuse yeah just
excuses
poor me
um when the you when you realize you're
arguing from emotion right now
are you gonna let me finish I just
wanted to point that out but yeah go
ahead all right did you ask what I think
you asked what I think
well the pay Gap is more concrete than I
mean I asked what I mean when you take
into account the number women work Less
hours right don't do the most would you
say that's true women work Less hours
yes statistically that's true did you
say okay would you say it's true that we
don't do the most dangerous jobs in
society yes statistically
would you would you agree that the
majority if you look at female
billionaires the richest women came from
divorce
okay
yeah that's true I guess I think so okay
so what what are we complaining about
what does that have to do with the pay
Gap any of that because all of those fat
you don't think working less hours
contributes to getting paid less yeah
but you know the pay Gap excuse me sorry
I've got phlegm in my throat so what
you're doing is you're misrepresenting
what the pay Gap is you understand that
the pay Gap when it's analyzed by
economics
economists and the U.S Department of
Labor and such organizations they
control they do controlled analysis
where they eliminate all these factors
for example ones you listed of women
tending to work in lower paid fields
they eliminate
women working less they eliminate for
when women take maternity leave all this
kind of stuff and even when you do a
controlled analysis where you eliminate
that there's still a big pay Gap
that true okay okay it's like it wasn't
at like three percent last time I
checked it was three percent
oh so there is a pay Gap
yeah but that's three percent
so but it's not a myth if there's three
percent
yeah but the I mean the number they used
to push was like 77 cents to the to the
dollar well that's what it is without
the it's about 20 without the without
yeah the control yeah right and so
yeah I mean when women
like I just think if we wanted to be
equal then do the same jobs men do but
there is a buy but that's interesting
because you don't admit there is a there
is a pig up three percent I mean I
wouldn't want to work for three percent
less
yeah I mean if you think that's because
of gender but it's also because women
are more agreeable it's like seven years
included that's part of the control
okay I mean I don't I don't think three
percent you can really say that's just
because of gender well I did some
research on this um the department of
labor labor published an in-depth report
this is under Trump's Administration in
2019.
this is from the U.S Department of Labor
I can lead you the uh the uh study if
you want it's called gender-based pay
disparity study
the research team found that the raw
gender wage Gap was 17.4 percent
and the medium was 20 the raw wage Gap
increased actually
between 50th and 75th percentile it
Remains the greatest at the highest
percentile in addition the research team
found that the importance of human
capital varied across wage distributions
and part-time work as well as female
oriented occupations uh the updated
result explained about 20 to 70 percent
of the raw wage Gap over the wage
distribution but it left
an adjusted wage gap of 10 to 15 percent
that was in 2019.
according to the U.S Department of Labor
yeah I mean I'd have to look at that but
the stuff I've seen it's very small it's
like three percent what what stuff Have
you seen
um off the top of my head I can't I
can't remember but I can send it to you
sure but I just gave you a pretty
concrete I mean the U.S Department of
Labor do you consider that a credible
Source yeah yeah I mean if if that's
true it's just a lot of times like there
there are like parts of the study that
they don't talk about so
like even on this is what I was looking
at earlier like they're saying the stat
you gave earlier 12 on of abortions are
not done on the surgery table of the
emergency room these cases are
overwhelmingly doctors advising
abortions ahead of time like ahead of
time in case there are risks for the
mothers in pregnancy also that 12 number
they give is highly inflated
um and so it's like it's just a lot of
times there's more to it than just like
a number you're giving me but yeah what
does that have to do with the pay Gap
I'm confused by that no the the point is
that like a number you gave me earlier
like there was more to it which number
which one I'm sorry go ahead we'll
unpack that
the the 12 of abortions are not done on
the surgery on the surgery table of the
emergency room these cases are
overwhelmingly doctors advising
abortions ahead of time in case there
are risks for the mother in person that
sounds reasonable to me
I mean a doctor is qualified to say this
baby is going to put your life at risk I
would trust the doctor to say that
wouldn't you
yeah
they're saying that number's inflated
who's saying they didn't they didn't say
that that what you read did not say it's
inflated uh no I said also that 12
number they're giving you is highly
inflated based on what because what you
just read to me doesn't disprove what I
said at all it actually makes perfect
sense no but they're saying it's
inflated I don't know they did not say
that who's they yeah they didn't say
that
who's they
um it's just someone I do research with
so it's so just someone
yeah um that's good okay that's fair
that's fair don't push right
um
here's an interesting analysis I thought
maybe you'd be interested
[Music]
um
women don't do the dangerous jobs women
uh are over represented in health care
you know that probably right yeah it's
the number one employer is nursing then
hopefully you can explain to me why
when you look at the pay of women versus
men doctors look you can see this graph
there's a huge disparity of the average
wage of male doctors versus female
doctors uh you can see here and even
this is from 20 to 22 last year uh this
is again from the uh physician
compensation report
um
male doctors make on average 285 000 per
year female doctors make on average 228
000 per year
so this is the woman's field
and yet they're still making significant
significantly less than their male
counterparts
okay does it say why no this is raw diet
this is just raw data
I mean you'd have to look at it why
so so this is so we could justify this
by
saying women work Less hours no but it
would work with less hours
this is controlled they're working the
same hours they have the same
qualifications
um yeah okay well then maybe they are in
that field I don't know okay so the wage
Gap is more complicated perhaps than
saying it's a myth
it's possible okay that's nice to hear
so I would recommend though when you go
out and do these shows and stuff because
when you talk about the wage Gap you're
very adamant about it like oh this is
this is a myth and this is this is why
and you you extract a lot of meaning
from it so I would recommend potentially
approaching that topic with a little
more Nuance in the future
[Music]
especially if you're saying well yeah
maybe I'm wrong about this um but here I
mean here's a here's an excerpt so we
can kind of see how you talk about these
issues here it is I think in 2022 any
girl that can plan I'm not talking about
risk risk first thing people and I'm
talking about female to male
um I I think in 2022 if you're
complaining about the pay Gap as a woman
you're probably just lazy
um I have never had a problem same pay
as a guy um one issue is that women no
so you you you you you kind of agree
that women who complain about pay are
just lazy yeah the majority of the women
complaining about this stuff
um
what do you mean majority of women oh my
gosh the majority of the women
complaining about this
miners just do what I see whiners
yeah I mean because women it's like go
you're arguing from emotion again
oh no oh no you literally are just
saying stuff yeah it's not that I
disagree I'm just saying if we want to
have a conversation about this stuff
it'd be better if we don't argue from
emotion and say I feel that all women
are complainers because that I mean
that's not a productive point
right and you see what I mean
yeah
um no I still think that most women that
complain about the pay Gap are just
whiners um they're big whiners and I
have never had a trial trouble getting a
job I've never had trouble getting the
same pay as a guy and I think that in
2023 it's just a bunch of excuses so
what's your experience in the uh work
you you use your own experience
as an example of uh why
women uh pay Gap doesn't exist no I'm
not I mean I'm not blind like you can't
hold on what's your experience in the
workforce
um I worked in I always had a job
um from like After High School in the
Summers
um and I worked in Corporate America and
then I did how long did you work in
Corporate America
a couple years couple years I haven't
only I'm only I'm only I'm only 26.
right you're only you're only 26 and
therefore I wouldn't put you in the and
you have maybe one or two years working
in Corporate America do you think that
your experience is ample to say I've
seen that women get paid equally to men
that seems disingenuous based on one
year or two years and you're only 26
years old
yeah um that's just my opinion
right okay
okay but I think we've established a
little bit at least you've conceded a
tiny bit to me that the wage Gap is
perhaps more complicated than yes or no
[Music]
if what you're showing me is real you
did this you did this to someone else
and then there was like something else
to it but if what you're showing me is
true yeah it's all true this is all
sorts yeah
and I mean you could easily look this up
yourself all right can I see the
parameters for the control I'm just
curious
sure we can do that yeah
uh you can pull up the U.S Department of
Labor one uh the the the doctor one can
I see
uh
uh by the way we it's we've long since
moved past but uh I did find that study
in the Rolo Tony video
um the Swedish study from uh several
years ago about Swedish uh prison system
I'm not sure
we can loop back to that wait what was
it what was it I I'm unfamiliar uh here
I had a bunch of tabs open where did it
go in the meantime here I'll uh I'll
send this in the zoom chat if you want
to take a look oh can you open it
because I I don't have the zoom on my
computer I can't send a link to you uh
that I guess that's what parameters won
that's the uh Department of Labor's 2019
study
um there's a couple more I guess we
didn't do I'm curious what do you think
it is the wage Gap
well it's complicated right I don't
think it's as simple as saying
it's uh it's a myth and women who
complain are lazy that doesn't seem like
a a productive
mm-hmm uh point to start that
conversation it is complicated like what
is your solution like if you you seem to
think that the wage Gap is is real right
and that women do you think women are
discriminated against yeah definitely
absolutely because like like what
barriers do women have today
in 2023 like I just genuinely don't
understand it's not about barriers it's
about uh it's about Norms it's about
like patriarchy it's about uh social the
way that we perceive the value of people
it's not about barriers there's no laws
that say women can't do this and that
obviously
okay so there's no barriers
right now no not that I could think of
okay transparency I mean
I agree that in general
um
you know
because
go ahead all right go ahead Sorry God
I do think that there's a bit of
discrimination going on I do think that
uh behind closed doors when there's no
transparency in payment
um this presupposition by the way that
you putting forward that women are lazy
and just making excuses that doesn't
help
um that uh honestly it's it's hot I
don't know how to explain it but I know
it exists right I know it is do you
think you think the the boss is behind
closed doors or we should hire less
women no it's not a conscious thing
right it's systemic yeah is then do you
have it like do you subconsciously pay
women less
um I don't think so no
okay
so then
yeah okay
I don't pay women
I'm just thinking if you think there's
this like subconscious thing yeah like
then you well but it does exist right I
mean
the women ask for raises at your well
we're talking about you saying it's a
myth okay yeah it's but it does exist
that's what's interesting
I just I don't think there's anything
stopping you today you could maybe argue
I can't even do it in my soul you can
maybe argue like 50 years ago but I just
think in 2023 there are no Berry
barriers didn't you say earlier 50 years
ago wasn't that long ago
in regardless okay fine 100 years ago
I'm saying I'm saying in the past you
could argue but in 2023
I just don't think there's anything
stopping you
I think it's like very much a victim
mindset to tell women like to go up
telling us that we're oppressed like I
think that I can do anything minus like
the physical stuff but I think I think I
can apply for any job a guy can if I
want I can go after any job that I want
I can ask for more money if I want and I
don't think that men are out there
discriminating against women I don't
think that I don't think that men are if
met like men are such capitalists men
want to make money it's like if women
were so much cheaper they would just
hire all women
right that's that's not how it works but
I've never claimed to have a solution
right I'm just saying there is a problem
you know I grew up in a family business
too so my my dad hired people all the
time like he had over 200 employees
wasn't your mom the president was she
the leader of the company
what was my are you researching my
family now huh that's all public my mom
my mom I mean I don't know what they
titled it like I don't know your mom was
the president I believe but based on it
I mean they might have they might have
titled it one thing or another my mom
did more of the Marketing sales side my
dad did the engineering and the software
okay
um I think they wanted to get some Grant
so I think like they might have had her
like they might have they did that to
get some Grant from the government or
something I don't remember
but so in this yeah is that a crime yeah
you probably shouldn't say that on air
yeah it might not like that
um so let's I guess you know again we're
we're kind of hitting a a wall on this
topic but what I would say is this is
that I don't claim to have a solution
I'm just I'm re-butting Yours claimed
that the pay Gap is a myth because it's
not a myth that exists I don't know how
to fix it I'm just saying it's not a
myth
that's an oversimplification and it's
dishonest
yeah yeah um
just don't
tribute and
it's the 77 cents to three percent like
is very different I think the majority
of the people three percent you can Oh
you mean the on control yeah it's more
than three percent but I agree that it's
lower yeah
and even even with that like
I I just would guess there's more to it
because I just don't see is there
anything else you want to guess I don't
think that men have this evil I think
it's silly it's silly to think that men
have this evil Coalition where they just
unconsciously discriminate against women
I agree and that's not what's happening
that's that's the over reciprocation
part speaking of uh coalitions what do
you think about the Jews
I'm just kidding I don't know I don't
know I'm just kidding I'm just kidding
me out I'm just kidding that's not a
serious question let's talk about some
of your uh really interesting ideas on
this one here you say men want young
women this is something I've heard you
say quite a bit a few times here I'll
play this clip to set it up that's not
will get me at 40 years old at 50 years
old it's getting a different version
than he had when I was 18 20 years old
but but it's a less valuable version to
men and no no it's not the right man for
me because
it's not the right man for you it's how
men like men can't help what they're
attracted to no it is all mad but they
can't if you survey men if you survey
men between the ages of 20 and 80
they're all the most attracted to 22
year olds I peaked three years ago and
and and and you guys did too whether you
yeah
20 22-23 and and this is men age of 20
and 80. so what men value is Purity
Youth and fertility and so like what
would you be able to offer to a guy
so that's something I've heard you say
Obviously you strongly believe that
right that men
that women who are past the age of 22
their value goes down
and um
men all men just want to want young
girls
um
so I guess what what's the what's the
message behind this what is it who are
you speaking to and what is it that I
mean it's just true men do want younger
women
right I want to ask you this before we
get into that what is your message who
are you speaking to and what is it
you're hoping that they take from this
I mean I just believe in speaking about
things that are true
um and I I think a lot of times as women
we're told that we can just wait forever
get married at 35 and have a bunch of
kids and that's just not true
um I just think it's the message that's
pushed by the media and culture today
um so the media is telling women to get
married at 35. I mean what have you ever
seen like what's a homemaker that's on
TV
you mean like in a sitcom or you mean
like in a no no but I'm saying like we
don't have them in the media and the
culture like family really isn't it it's
really family really isn't isn't pushed
um and so I'm not saying it to dog on
women but I just think a lot of times
like we're lied to I mean we have now we
have men are called ageist
ageist if they don't want younger women
you know they're constantly men are
constantly shamed when they have a
standard
um so
it's not I mean that's like a
conversation from I don't know a three
hour episode I don't remember that why
don't you bring it up a lot I know that
yeah because it's because it's true and
a lot of times women you're speaking to
women you're saying past 22
going down
and yes and your message
your value on the sexual Marketplace so
your value like that doesn't mean like
your personal worth I'd like to just
clarify that but yeah and so your
message to them is nothing you're just
saying that because it's true I mean
maybe don't don't wait till you know 35
to get married get married as young as
you can right as young as you can yeah
now you seem to offer a lot of advice to
who you're mostly giving advice to women
would you say I know I don't really I
wouldn't really okay
uh
I wouldn't really
excuse me I guess sure sure yeah that's
fair
I mean I think I've heard you say that
even and then so men like I would I
wouldn't say I'm like an advice Channel
like do this do this do this I mean it's
more talking about the state of
relationships today is a better way that
I would put it
excuse me so as men
get older not like super old but their
value goes up
and as a man's value on the sexual
Marketplace goes up they're looking for
younger
virgins right that's important
and so any woman who's not well
historically virginity has always been a
prerequisite for marriage like a hundred
years ago 85 of women didn't admit to
premarital sex so
you know it's more abnormal now that
women are not virgins anymore do you
know what an appeal to a tradition is
doesn't doesn't uh predict anything well
I'm saying the outcomes are better for
women like the outcomes are obviously
better we have more women on
antidepressants than ever before and you
know and you know it's tough because
there are studies both ways when it when
it comes to female happiness but most of
the ones that I've seen indicate that
women are
unhappy over a certain age without
children and most women wanted to have
kids at some point in their life
um and I just think and you know you
could see what happens in front of you
like you're not blind women are happier
with the family
um so then again you're doing the I'm
not blind I see I see this which is like
again kind of an emotional argument
antidepressants didn't exist on my
emotional today that's just your your
go-to today well I'm trying it's just
it's hard to have a conversation with
somebody's face the sex is in my face in
this country I just get called emotional
well it's hard to have a conversation
with somebody who just says I feel this
you know what I mean it's like how do
you how do you address that in a
conversation you say I see this I'm not
blind I mean that's not really a
concrete well I I listed
the before that let's talk about those
antidepressants didn't exist 100 years
ago what relevance does that have on the
happiness of women then and now
I mean
I just we're seeing them get more and
more on Android well men are on
antidepressants too I think though we're
not talking we're not talking about men
but you know men and women are getting
all antidepressants at the same rate why
can't we have a conversation about women
without talking about the men because it
doesn't it's like 90 I can't I can't
answer questions if you keep
interrupting me what I'm trying to
answer you go ahead you know so it's
like 90 of women are uncontraceptive or
have been on contraceptives at some
point in their life one out of three
women has one out of four women have an
STD one out of three women has had an
abortion
um it's like these aren't good number
like do you genuinely think that
sleeping around is good for women
I don't think in my opinion Mass
sleeping around like you're talking
about like 100 plus Partners isn't good
for men or women
sleeping with multiple partners is good
I think it's completely fine I don't
think there's an issue with women do you
think do you think no do you think it's
good for them
do you think it's good for I think it
depends on the person in the
relationships I mean the the premise is
neutral the premise doesn't imply you
know people men and women have good and
bad relationships some benefit them some
don't hmm
overall multiple partners you would say
good for women or bad for women I
literally cannot answer that question
because it makes no sense it depends on
the relationships
but let's say this I'll answer it I'll
say I think it's good to get more
experiences in life and to have multiple
partners I think it's good yeah I I
think it's not good why
um I I think as it leads to more
heartbreak heartbreak yeah like women
sleeping with multiple people
I just don't I don't think that's a good
thing you don't you can get heartbroken
without sleeping
yeah but
that's true but I just don't think it's
the same women attached through you
think it's not the same
sex too by the way yeah but we're not
talking about men I'm talking about
women but you so I don't I don't think I
don't think sleeping around is great for
men either but I don't think it's the
same for men and for women hold on you
keep saying let's talk about women and I
just want to say and if there is a
communal experience
then it's it's worth bringing up like
you say more women are antidepressants
but if men are on antidepressants in the
same trajectory then that would imply
that it doesn't have to do with anything
to do with women being promiscuous it's
more of a societal thing that affects
both genders equally
mm-hmm
yeah
um wait say that one more time I'm sorry
if men and women are both
on antidepressants at the same rate then
that would that would suggest something
on a larger societal issue and not
because women are promiscuous so I think
that is worth I mean you could argue a
lot of societal issues have come from
women being promiscuous okay
so I mean you could you could if 85
percent of women were virgins 100 years
ago and everyone's in antidepressants
Society perfect 100 years ago maybe
maybe it doesn't have good outcomes for
women
Society was perfect 100 years ago when
women were virgins I had to say perfect
but there was more intact families which
the life expectancy was like 50 back
then just right I I did not say I don't
know what does that have to do with
anything well you're saying the quality
of life the I mean things were better
back no I said we no that's I said we
had more intact families which I think
is important
okay
uh let's talk about the where were we
were talking about uh
we were on the topic of
uh men wanting uh younger women
here did I finish this clip I just
learned a lot from them so I'd love to
hear this side oh this is the pig up one
sorry
um
men want younger women we watched this
whole clip
so I I was just trying to basically
apply it to your life if I can it's like
so older men when they have money
they have status
they're gonna want a younger
and um
more virgin woman
mm-hmm
so I I have a bit of a question and I
I'm being honest here is it possible
for and you look at men right in terms
of like their viability you look at me
and say he's a high value man he's a
medium value man he's a low value man
right I mean we could say that we can
put men into those categories okay
so let's say you're you're in the dating
uh field right you're you're looking for
a partner
right
um what do you mean I mean you're single
essentially I guess and you're looking
for significance maybe maybe not okay
okay so um
if you're looking for men
if a man who is willing to settle let's
say you're not that old but you're 26
and you say that anyone over 25 is
like uh almost damaged goods or getting
worse and worse no
it's less valuable it's less valuable
correct yes I would say I was
I was more valuable by five years ago
yes in terms of the dating Market yes so
do you think that
how can somebody who's older and not a
virgin and less valuable how can they
get in a relationship with a man and not
think they're a loser
because if you're a low value woman then
in a sense you be judging the guy who's
said quote unquote settling for you
because he couldn't get a higher value
woman
so in a sense a guy that you would
settle for would be a loser by your own
by your own metrics low value what are
what are Men supposed to do 95 percent
of women aren't virgins on their wedding
days you could be a multi-millionaire
and not get a virgin
I think that's why you see more men
walking away from relationships uh no no
no how do you enter a relationship and
not think that he's a loser because he's
low value
oh
I don't really know how to answer that
question but it is interesting right
because in a sense only a low value man
and I'm sorry I'm only I'm only framing
this in your world view let's say A
medium value man what would would decide
to settle on somebody like you who's a
little bit older not as fertile not as
fertile you are not a virgin and also
I'll tell you something else you like
being in the foreground which is not
good for traditional marriages I mean
he's looking for someone who wants to
build a home you don't know how to cook
I don't I don't I don't expect to be
with like a high value guy I think
that's silly okay um what's yours
because when I when I think of high
value I think of like top five percent
of men so what value do you think you'll
be settling on in your own personal life
what
what value will I be settling yeah what
man do you think is reasonable for you
to pursue
I I just kind of I think that's a bit of
a inappropriate like question that's
interesting because you spend like all
day talking about this stuff I find that
it's really interesting to have you and
put this analysis into use how why is it
the way you're framing the way you're
framing the question is a bit
disingenuous
um I think I think most women and you
know disingenuous
foreign
yeah I just I think it's a bit
disingenuous
why why is it disingenuous I'm analyzing
your viability by your own metrics which
you do all day to other women and men
why is that disingenuous
okay
like I think it's fair to say because
you were talking to women about
expectations and Men about expectations
based on their value I think it's fair
to say okay well what's your value of
man you're looking for based on your own
uh based on your own what's what's my
value to a guy that I'm no no no what
value I wish like I don't know what you
want me to say like I wish I I was a
virgin you know I should have waited no
no no no I don't know what
like I don't I don't you know most guys
don't expect that in 2023 unfortunately
um I think men adapt to the market but I
think to say that you should just sleep
around
um is is a bit silly that's not what I'm
asking I'm asking you were saying that
like that more Partners is good I think
that's a bit silly um okay
I'm talking about you your value by your
own metrics is going to be not super
high
mm-hmm yeah it's it's high than it was
five years ago but it's not even just
the age thing it's like you are you are
working you're in the foreground you
don't know how to cook these are not
good things for your score okay I'm
actually pretty I'm pretty good now I've
got you have a cook pattern okay good
you're working towards it but
unfortunately as you age those things
are going to bounce out yeah I mean
sometimes sometimes like you start in a
certain place in life but all you can do
is improve and get better that's
interesting I agree so what is the point
of telling people that they're
because a lot of times we're like we're
lied to we're not even told what men
want being told that men want younger
women is like crazy even though that's
that's not true by the way it's not
that's not true by the way men don't
want younger women they want okay Who's
hotter a 50 year old is equally as hot
as a 20 year old just based on looks and
nothing else
yeah it could be I mean it could be
um but like how do you meet a guy that
you respect because he's settling on you
don't you see that there's a paradox
here
I mean if you respect men you don't like
but how can you how are you going to
settle for a low value man because like
that it's like dude come on
a low value man a low value I think I
think if you get married you're lucky to
get married
that's my opinion okay so so I would I
would feel I would feel very lucky
um if I was married I would feel so
you'll take anything
no I won't take anything it's a bit
silly your your standard I didn't say
that's not what I said but okay you said
I'll be happy if I get married I don't
you know what I mean hey yeah anybody I
didn't I didn't say to anyone
hmm
how would you so where's your value as a
woman would you say like on a scale of
one to ten
I give myself like a five a five yeah
that's fair I think I mean based on your
metric I'm not saying one way or the
other
so we're looking for I think yeah I
think I'm a five so so you're saying
that all men want to uh have sex with
younger women this is kind of
interesting data but are you aware that
the MILF category is like the most
popular it was the number one most
searched term in 2018 MILF
yeah men like to have sex with older
women but why is it the most searched
for
foreign
are you saying are you saying porn is
the same thing as marriage and
relationships you say men want to have
sex with young girls why then are
married when you say young girls that's
a bit okay 22 I mean what do you want me
to say okay young women 22 year olds why
then are they going to Pornhub and
looking up MILFs if they just want to if
they prefer and this is the most
searched
wouldn't they be searching for like teen
or something
2018 yeah you know men aren't that picky
you know what I mean no no no it's not
about picky it's about Preference they
looked right okay so I have a question
why do you think like the the number one
like they swipe right on younger women
do you think it said you think do you
think it's equal an 18 year 22 year old
versus a 50 year old woman
now I'm asking do you think it's equal
are you equally attracted to the average
55 year old versus 22 year old
I would be more equally uh attracted to
someone closer to my age where I am in
life I think
okay yeah I would maybe like minus five
years
yeah but younger typically
not older minus five years younger
right plus or minus right okay you said
younger first but I'm telling you plus
or minus okay okay there's no take
backsies
no take back you say younger
yeah but so why do you how do you
explain that I didn't want to date most
women want to date five to seven years
older I think men go like five years
younger is there any way to explain why
MILF is the um
most search category guys like to watch
you know a hot mom have sex more than a
young girl have sex apparently
are they the top porn stars because I
thought those were younger women I
thought it was like
the ones that I mean I don't actually
watch that stuff so I don't know I don't
know the stats but I'm just telling you
based on search that people are looking
up MILF way more than teen and stuff
like that so that's interesting though
do you do you do you think it's better
for a woman to get married at 35 than
22.
I think it's neutral I think it it
depends on a lot of things
I do think women who get married young
have a higher rate of divorce
yeah it's like below the age like
21 or 18 or something I don't remember
so that kind of disproves your thesis
doesn't it
if younger women are getting divorced
overall younger is better than older but
more and you're the youngest the
youngest not younger
but we also wait to get married the
average age of first marriage in the UK
is like 31. yeah but our life expectancy
is like double what it was so it's not
really a fair that doesn't change it
doesn't change biology like so when it
comes to children like women are still
the most fertile when they're younger so
I mean we can have a cultural shift but
that doesn't change your biology
well we have a scientific shift too we
have methods of of making it easier for
older older women to have uh babies
[Music]
yeah so like the cultural shift is
taxing the scientific it's not just IVF
there's fertility treatments you can get
I've done it with my wife it's it's less
invasive it's like taking hormones and
stuff and so they're so the the science
I can pull up the numbers but I'm PR the
majority of IVF fails
especially over a certain age I can pull
it up
um so but so I think it's and it's
expensive too it's like the average IVF
is like thirty thousand dollars yeah
most fertility treatments is an IVF
there's there's less invasive less
impactful less expensive things that you
can do that are really effective right
right I mean you can but again most
people are living paycheck to paycheck
they can't afford a bunch of fertility
treatments okay like I think that's easy
for you to do right you're in a great
position it should be free average but
no you know I don't I don't think that
you should pay for other people's
decisions you know um I think if you
want to make that decision you should
pay for it but I just think that's an
easy thing for you to say when you're in
like you're I'm you do you do such great
numbers I'm sure you do really well
income wise thank you for saying that
do you should we we don't pay we
shouldn't pay for what other people do
should we pay for prisoners or should we
execute them all
those are my only options well we
shouldn't pay for pay for prisoner
execute them okay right that's extreme
in a sense though I'm trying to make it
like uh uh somewhat like uh because it's
a tough question prisoners cost on
average like thirty thousand dollars a
year for the average prisoner yeah
because the IVF is obviously way cheaper
than that
mm-hmm
so what do we do about them
well or what else I mean what what what
would you do with prisoners we're
spending forty five thousand dollars a
year what do we do with them
yeah the average is yeah it looks like
forty five thousand forty five thousand
IVF probably costs like ten thousand
the
I mean
what are they in prison for I don't know
much about uh it's kind of it's kind of
different you know topic but I do think
we should execute well they're all
costing us the same amount of money
and murderers yeah we can the rest I
don't really know I don't have a strong
opinion but IVF in general in general I
guess you know I guess prison would make
a bit more sense because you want a safe
Society so that's something everybody
benefits from but I don't I don't
benefit if Susie down the streets Waits
waits till she's 35 to get married but
then her family will be stronger she's
less likely to get divorced the kids
will grow up in a stable household I
mean or she could do that when she's
younger like again but that's not how it
works and you know that you look at the
stats younger people are more likely to
get divorced young people don't make as
much money younger people have less time
to spend right what do you what do you
mean by Young so like I think the stat I
saw was under the age of 21. but it's
like between above that the divorce
rate's very similar do you think women
under 21 should get married
um yeah if they want to
um I think you know people I'm not
forcing anyone to do anything but I
think more time you spend with a husband
rather than just like out on The Dating
Market I think that's better I think
less experience is better
uh so
here is an interesting uh and now
regarding men wanting to sleep with
uh younger women the top so I've been
trying to source that figure
how old is Abella danger how old is she
uh how old is ABBA she's 27. that's
pretty old in your world isn't it
on a Rhodes Riley Reed yeah but that's
not a MILF
it's like uh
Lana Rose is 26 26. yeah yeah but again
1828. okay just because they're the most
popular doesn't mean it's the most
popular category also they're 26 is over
the hill right I got the top the top
categories I have is ebony lesbian
threesomes I don't see any 22 year old
head large uh mainstream porn star I
mean 22 versus 26. it's not that like we
say 18 and 28 is a woman's Peak
20 what is the warmest piece between 18
and 28. um I mean it slowly declines
after after like 22 or 23 it slowly
declines but 18 to 28 Peak as in what
what does peak mean Peak like looks wise
okay looks wise
hmm so I've been trying you this claim
that men between ages 20 and 80 want to
have sex with 22 year olds I haven't
been able to find any source for that
the only source I've been able to find
is from this book The Prisoners to work
say what can we put the prisoners to
work they already do yeah they're slaves
already they work for like 10 cents an
hour yeah but only to profit private
corporations by the way it doesn't
benefit you at all
okay yeah yeah it's not a good system
damn you seem very knowledgeable on the
prison system I'm not a I want to call
myself a prison expert yeah and that's
that's fair we don't need to I don't
expect you to be so in terms of sourcing
this claim that old men want to have sex
with not old men all men want to have
sex with 22 year olds around that age
the only source for that I could find
they find they find that that the most
attractive the only source for that I
could find was a book called what's the
okay yeah uh this the the way that these
numbers are sourced is pretty pretty
poor so it's not really that high
quality of us of a of a source but I'll
read you the the results it does say
that meant 20 to 50 find 23 year olds
most attractive but in the same study it
says but women that men find most their
most interested in are women of their
similar age
but they found the 23 year olds the most
attractive but not the most
Source interested in and desirable
I think I mean how do they did they they
just asked them it's yeah the whole of
the audience it wasn't even really a
study this was a book and I'm sorry if
this isn't what you got your statistics
from but it was the closest thing that
we could find to the stats that you were
laying out and it did again it has shown
that 20 to 50 men
when asked who they find the most
attractive the answers generally fall in
that range 20 to 23. however this wasn't
really a study this was a book by the
CEO of OkCupid and he was basing all of
this off of analyzing the raw dating the
raw data from OkCupid and this was in
2014 so it was about a decade ago but
the but they're most interested right
and and they found the same conclusion
that Ethan just pointed out that though
they may find younger women more
attractive who they are interested in
dating Falls generally much closer to
their own age but if you have a better
Source on that I'd love to hear it
because I we live even if you look at
dating app data like what because it all
starts with that's what this is this is
but I'm saying it starts it starts with
looks for men you're not going to get in
the door unless you look a certain way
yeah
there's some older women that sure right
um that look good enough to get into the
door but it starts with swiping and that
starts with look so if they find the 22
year olds the most attractive that's
what you need to get in the door first
it's not it's not to say that every
woman over the age of 30 or 35 is like
done for completely but
um it's going to be a lot harder and I
think it's dishonest to say it's going
to be equally as easy to date when
you're 35 versus 22.
yeah I didn't say that
you're saying men you're saying men men
tend to in general like younger women
they're but find younger women more
attractive but they're interested
everything starts but men it starts with
looks so you don't get into the door
unless you look a certain way I think
you're making a big generalization about
all men okay do you disagree with that
you don't think it starts I think a lot
of men have a lot of different
preferences and I think a lot of men's
consideration of what attractive as a
huge variance as well
So when you say good looks get you in
the door and the attraction is pretty
subjective don't you think
I think that it starts with looks for
men and looks is pretty subjective I
would say no I would say it's not I
would say men tend to find the same
things attractive beauty is objective
based on what an interesting take okay
based on what
um I would say dating app data
um which ones
I don't know off the top of my head
Ethan from Okay Cupid said men are most
interested in men of their own age
they find women the most attractive at
22. 20 23.
my argument I don't want to date them
though they find them anymore
you guys don't let me finish
um is my my argument is you need looks
to get in the door
so like what does that have to do that's
not the most attractive
men tend to find younger women more
attractive I think you have a really I
think I think it's like dishonest to say
do you really think it's equally as easy
to date for a woman at 35 versus 22.
again nobody said that
okay okay do you think it's harder for
the 35 year old in general I think
there's less options as you get older
yeah of course
and yeah absolutely
dude do you think it's equal do you
think men have less options equally as
much as women as they get older yeah I
don't know I mean who [__] knows
no I'm asking your opinion you're asking
my opinion my opinion is that it's
probably similar probably similar if
women yeah see I disagree because I even
I think that the most no I saw a
different I think it was either Okay
Cupid or Plenty of Fish I can't remember
which one but it was like the most
swiped right on age for women was 18 and
the most swiped right on age well that's
just volume dude I mean there's way more
younger people on on dating apps than
older for sure like if you look the age
distribution it'd be a vast majority of
younger yeah well and and when they
asked men what age they prefer to date I
think it was like five to seven like
five years younger was the average in
women it was five to seven years older
so even if we just go off of women's
preferences like men would have more
options when they get older because
women want older men
that's all just you're just saying stuff
I mean you're just saying stuff based on
what you think is real I don't think any
of that is necessarily true I mean I
could again I could find it I mean I
don't have like a team like you guys
have yeah but well you say this stuff
all the time on your shows so I would
expect you to be somewhat familiar with
the I mean I I it just depends on like
sometimes you forget which one sure
you want to name a couple it could be
from
give me a second I'll find it
did you know that the number one five
porn star of all time is uh
uh Lisa Ann she's 51 years old
Brandy Love is is number eight she's 50.
they like MILFs man
like MILFs they like experienced women
that know what they're doing they like
men like that do you think that men want
that for relationships do you think men
want to date a child for relationships
because they're more attractive for free
I think men prefer younger women in
general in relationships yes that's just
I'm sorry but fat but that does that's
not even backed up by your own data
because men are more younger than them
typically younger than them that's
that's a different that's not men want
to date 22 year olds a 50 year old
they're the most they're the most
attracted to 22 year olds and look skate
to you in the door
yeah but it doesn't just get you in the
door that's just step one you're saying
different things in this culture if a
man is walking around with a 22 year old
people are gonna think that's weird
people think two out of the five it says
two out of the five top porn star porn
porn stars in PornHub are 23 and under
and all of the people that you're
listing started Young
oh so they're old now yeah they got the
they got the they built their fan base
I don't think it really works that way
but they're all they shouldn't be
stationed it works that way you guys are
in media you know damn well that you
build a fan base what do you think
they're YouTubers they're not doing
Minecraft let's play they're they're
naked
come on
I don't find that that analysis very
interesting and apparently you don't
either because
sweetie fox22
yeah there's porn stars who are 22. yeah
yeah of course
the majority the majority are younger
not the popular ones
the most popular ones are younger the
most popular ones are younger
they're like in late 20s you know my
dog's barking one second
bye
[Applause]
all right I let her outside it's kind of
hot in here
um
I want to ask you the number one porn
star is 23.
who
uh it's either let me see it's
Eva
who's the number one because
I just don't think it really number one
foreign
but even if that's true I don't think
that refutes anything I mean it's
possible that number one is 23 but uh
number one you just said it you just
said it refuted it if that the number
one search was MILFs
right well it counters your argument
okay let's move on there's just
arguments in circles here
um
I want to talk about this a little bit
more
higher body count is that the 2018 poll
citing a 2018 poll and the 2022 numbers
show that the MILF drops
the MILF drops but it's exciting 2018
poll and the 2022 numbers show that the
MILF drops it's top five most searched
number one in UK southern Asia Canada
that it was 2018. yeah the 2018. it says
the 2022 one that dropped oh so men
became less interested in older women in
the last five years I guess
MILF was number one search term this
year in the UK southern Asia Canada and
Netherlands yeah yeah and it was in the
top five most searched for terms in
Paris Italy Mexico Spain Poland Ukraine
Argentina Sweden and Belgium this year
and Lana Rhodes is number one and she's
26.
but whatever who cares let's move on
okay I disagree listen I disagree
there's not a lot of data on this like
there's really no data to make a
conclusion so again I I just don't think
it's fair for when you talk about these
things to say oh science says this data
shows this but there's no data that
shows any of that I mean it's just again
you feel that way you feel it talked
about we just talked about that men find
22 year olds the most attractive yeah
you can interpret the data differently
than me that's finally we can it's not
really data that was some random blog
from the book we can I mean there's also
dating app data and then you guys if you
guys interpret it differently than me we
can interpret it differently but and you
could come to one conclusion
disagree let's agree to disagree on this
one
um so tell me
we didn't really get to flush this out
but I find this topic interesting
why is a woman with a high body high
body count and high I guess is like 10
plus what is high
well it depends depends what guys you
ask you know
I mean in my in my opinion
um
I really think it's best to be a virgin
when you get married so
um I didn't do that I wish I did but I
think it's best to be a virgin
okay but like what would you consider a
high body count if in general when men
are looking for considering such a thing
it seems like the the body count studies
that I've seen it drops around like five
to seven seven
okay so so what is inherently less
desirable about a woman with five to
seven partners
um I mean one what what value does that
bring to a guy
um well it's neutral
yeah I mean I just thinking what
devalues it not what value is it
what devalues it
um
I I think that you have more X's to
compare your current partner oh so it's
insecurity
so you would be insecure if you want to
label it that way but it's like what why
would you want someone with more X's
five to seven sexual partners means that
there's too much to compare me to and
therefore you might think that I'm
inadequate because you've had better
partners
well it's also like the rate women are
happier when they're virgins on their
wedding day so that is just something
you said
no look I mean you can look up the
studies on body count again
yeah we can fact check that it just
seems like something you just say
um it's like from The Family Institute
something and Family Institute okay but
so while we look that up let's say what
so so women are happier but the more
sexual partners a woman has the less
happy she tells I'm asking you what is
less attractive because you talk about
men are looking for women who have had
less sexual partners so what is less
attractive what makes them less
attractive
what makes them less such men don't want
hoes
men don't want women that have slept
with multiple people we're talking about
five to seven Partners why don't men
want hoes you do you want a woman with a
lot of bodies five to seven I don't
consider I think that's totally black
well I think most men would you know
pray for that nowadays but but
um but what do you mean most men would
pray for it because the number I looked
up is 10 of women who there's only 10 of
women in the United States have more
than 15
uh Partners the average number is 4.2
did that that study was for women it
included older women too though 25 to
44.
yeah that's the
that yeah I've I just think it would
probably be more accurate if you kept
women under like 35 but
um so what makes a hoe I don't know what
does this mean
I mean I it depends on who you ask
I'm asking you clearly
what do I think
I mean from a historical perspective
really a virgin like I I think you
should be a virgin on your wedding day
okay that's again
but what's that have to do with Min
being attract you said men don't want to
date hoes I just want to unpack that
men don't want to date hoes
I don't know what that means if I can be
totally honest with you
I prefer a woman with less sexual
experience than more
a less well so I I I gotta disagree with
you I just don't think that's true I
don't think men care I don't think men
care how many sexual partners their
women have had unless it's like a
hundred but that's true of men men who
have had 100 sexual partners are also
pretty uh do you think women care about
Drake's body count
women want to sleep with Drake and like
other celebrities do you think they care
about their body count are we talking
about it
I mean Drake's a celebrity men are
lining up to date like Lana Rhodes Mia
Khalifa and like actually being crazy
dude are you crazy do you really believe
that dude men would there there is quite
literally that would literally give
their mind to do you can't believe that
yeah yeah and one with the most options
that's what they want to do
men with the most options want to do
what we're not talking about men with
the most options are you talking about
women with the most options when it
comes to Drake
are you just talking about average fans
I'm talking about Drake does not have a
problem getting laid because of his body
count I would imagine that right
I would imagine that porn stars would
have a hard time getting into marriage
with a man that they respect and admire
aren't you the one that's always being
like let's not talk about Fringe cases
what's the point of bringing up Drake
that's like the most extreme example
wouldn't you agree I mean we could even
go into like normal dating I think
that's more important yeah
I just think it's silly to argue that
men want to date women with high body
counts no they don't want to I'm saying
I don't think it matters especially the
number you gave me five to seven yeah
five to seven I don't think men care
about that in general I just don't I
mean you could argue 15 to 20 25 like I
I don't know exactly what point but
usually there is a point for most men
I don't think
it's equal
it's not equal because Drake
no not because of Drake
because we should remove like celebrity
and outside kind of influences from this
because that obviously creates
um
unusual yeah Fringe cases which we don't
like we don't like to talk about those
oh so then what about the abortion one I
was just parody
I was just joking yeah
all right one last thing I I see that
we're getting exhausted here it's fine
Drake's saying I want a few I want a
girl with a future and a past
that's a that's a lyric of his
he wants an experienced girl even
Drake's talking about in his damn lyrics
Drake doesn't want a virgin you just you
just said no
said you're crazy how you just threw
that out the window now you don't want
to talk about it Craig wants a girl with
a future and a past oh stop his Sim
pandering music to women he makes money
off of that
women are like come on strike
all right let's talk about one last
seems like a creepy probably yeah and I
do thank you for being here you know
it's it's combative but uh I think it's
a good conversation I wanted to ask you
about one last thing
this comment I thought was interesting
and tell me uh
what you think about it yes I found
similar to the slavery stuff too because
that's that's literally they they the
founder of or the guy who made Roots
said I wanted a myth for my people to
live by so they often but that's what
they do is they embellish and I'm not
trying to say it wasn't horrible it was
right but they want to make it like more
horrible so that they can control people
so in what way was slavery made to seem
more horrible than it was
um we were talking about
I don't I don't really want to go into
this too much because we're kind of past
this but I was quoting a Thomas Sowell
book
so
yeah okay
who's that yeah so Thomas owl's an
author who talks about the history of
slavery
so okay so so but do you so do you agree
with that premise that slavery was
embellished or no
um I think that
there are parts that are under
embellished and there are parts that are
over embellished I think it just depends
what we're talking so interesting I've
got to know what was over embellished
about slavery
just like one example I'm dying to know
[Music]
yeah I just I just rather I mean I was
talking about a book that I read and I
think to understand the context you'd
have to read the book you just said some
parts were embellished some parts were
under the embellished I I just think are
you retracting that
I just I
I'd really just rather not
okay
slavery being embellished that's so
interesting I don't know how you
embellished it there are certain facts
that we're not allowed to talk about
like what I would love to we're doing
the taboo yeah we're mixing it up it's
red pill baby
let's see the world as it is
I just I genuinely want to know how it
was embellished yeah yeah what can't we
talk about come on
I mean I could show you the video I was
quoting but it's just I'd rather not get
into this so
sounds like a blue pilled attitude to me
yeah
um I just again I was kind of hoping
this was like a good faith interview
wait what sad faith I'm literally
showing you clips of you saying stuff
yeah I just I'm yeah wait hold on I'm
sorry I'm sorry what about this
interview has been bad faith
I just think you're kind of trying to
push an agenda and you're not
I just think you're trying that's a clip
of you saying that you can disavow it
that would be super easy to say I was
wrong interview where I'm quoting
somebody like if you watch the full
interview I am quoting somebody and now
you're trying to pin me down about a
topic that I don't dive into hold on so
it's like I don't have the point of my
channel
isn't it but you said it how is that bad
faith hold on let me see because I was
talking about how the founder of the guy
the
Thomas Sowell talks about how the guy
that made Roots talked about how it was
a myth for his people to live by okay
that's what the guy who made root set
Alex Haley okay
so and I can't even talk about that on a
podcast without being canceled by the
internet yeah but mythology you know you
know myth doesn't necessarily mean it's
a lie right just because these mythology
is like a culture history that doesn't
mean the way it's depicted in the movie
was how it actually happened
and that's that's what he was talking
about on the book but again I was
quoting a book and you're trying to like
pin me down on quoting a book
let me Swatch this again and see if I'm
doing that free stuff too because that's
that's literally they they the founder
of or the guy who made Roots for my
people to live by so they often but
that's what they do then you say but
here's what they do
and I'm not trying to say it wasn't
horrible I'm not trying to say it wasn't
horrible right but they want to make it
like more horrible they want to make it
more for that they can control people so
that they can control people right but
wait wait oh my gosh five minutes before
I say so will talks about this in his
book
so I'm I'm communicating in the
interview that I'm quoting an author
you're not being honest
you say I they do this to okay so you
disavowed just disavow it then that's
easy just say I don't think slavery was
embellished I mean that's super easy
that's like a layup
do you agree you know I mean it's like
just say you don't think slavery was
embellished I think there are certain
facts that you're not allowed to talk
about I don't really want to talk about
it but that that Roots was what is a
myth I I again there are certain facts
you're not allowed to talk about and I
don't really feel like getting into it
today so I miss so well compared Barack
Obama to Adolf Hitler do you like that
analogy
that's the author you're quoting
do you think that's a fair knowledge
that's a quite one-sided way to write
his whole work but he wrote like a
hundred books oh I'm just asking you do
you agree with that statement
Barack Obama is comparable to Adolf
Hitler
all right
no okay
see it's my heart it's not hard that's
awesome that's easy to do
you also said George Washington was
viewed about from his slaves like a
father
I guess that's part of what the the
part of the what the myth I guess is
that not all slave owners were evil some
were father figures like George
Washington
did you say that
I don't remember I think like if
someone's a great and powerful man in
history to the point like they're
talking about him hundreds of years
later he didn't have any kids but didn't
he own slaves what to be on slaves
George Washington yeah he did yeah not
Roman to me I'm just saying he actually
it's actually interesting he um
he had a different like he inherited his
slaves and it wasn't as simple as he
could have just like let them go because
um the debt that's incurred on them like
you can't just release them and so he
his slave's actually like he had a
really good relationship with them and
they considered him like a dad
what's your source for that
that was from a Thomas Sowell book
Thomas Soul so he's your guy Thomas
Souls the man Thomas Soul wrote a column
about supporting segregation in public
schools
George Washington you want me to
apologize like you want me to talk about
every single one of this man's opinions
no I just want you I just want to know
what you think do you think racism was
embellished I mean it's so easy I mean
just say no I think okay there was a
time I started to read accounts from
actual slaves so these were like in like
the and you know I can't really talk
about this like even if I talk about
this now they're gonna clip it they're
gonna say things I didn't I didn't say
but it's like I used to
read actual slave accounts and I was
surprised how many didn't say bad things
about their owners after they were free
and it's not to say like slavery was a
horrible institution but I can't talk
about that fact without getting canceled
I can't say hey these slaves had a good
relationship with their owners because
it's not true because it's just not true
it's not true what George Washington was
not a father figure to his slaves well
if you Rick look up like um I think it
was book 47 let's see 47 of George
Washington's slaves tried to escape
would you try to escape if you hello
maybe maybe that maybe that one was
wrong I don't I don't know this was like
okay a little bit on a podcast months
ago I don't really remember but and and
I said I wasn't sure if it was
Washington either in that interview
I mean I got I got months of backlash
for this I'm now like you guys are kind
of trying to do a gotcha mode no no no I
I didn't know about that really I didn't
know about the backlash I promise I
didn't I just want to know what you
think I had I had months of people like
you know it's like if I have this
conversation I had months of people
calling my employees slaves
like that's what they call like that's
that's horrible yeah I disagree that
sucks horrible but at the same time and
like even even the guy and you know this
because you watched the video of that
guy the reaction you just showed like
you got your you're acting oblivious so
I didn't know that but you do know that
because the reaction you just watched
was my former co-host who insinuated
that my my employees were being
colonized oh I'm sorry I didn't know
that I promise I just wanted to get your
take well people people say I just
wanted to know what your thoughts are on
this that's all
um yeah I'm not like my channel isn't
about slavery that's like a fringe oh
I'm just I want to know about you but
I'm asking like why are you bringing
this up when that's not really what my
channel is about I can't I can only ask
you things about I I this is interesting
I want to ask you about it but do I kind
of only ask you things in a confined
space yeah you can but you you
understand how that looks to me it's
like you're just trying to pick out
every single listen Pearl to be fair to
be totally fair you could just say I
don't think slavery was embellished
that's a layup for most people
foreign
I was quoting a book that's the crazy
part I was quoting a book
so do you agree with his statement
though
um do I think overall it was embellished
some parts sure there it is which part
no please tell me which part I think
tell me I think that you can't I think
that certain slaves had good
relationships with their owners not all
maybe not most but I think some did and
that just and there are accounts of
there are accounts of them saying this
so some slaves had good relationships
with their masters therefore slavery was
embellished I'm sure you know you know
how this is gonna go for me like I don't
know why you're doing this
you you know I can't have this
conversation without them painting it a
certain way well just own it then just
do it just say what you want you know I
mean just just be red pilled about it
who is they I don't know who's there
just your haters or someone
the left the left do they have
parentheses around the day like I mean
you even came in like you researched
like my family like that's that's weird
how is that weird it's all public the
stuff you talked about you literally
talked about it it's called preparation
like you literally do no preparation and
you talk like I did it I didn't talk
about if my mom was the president of
like where did we find that find that on
there let's look it up I said I Googled
who were your parents and it popped
right out is that yeah they're they're
relatively I didn't send a prize
interviews on YouTube there's all kinds
of stuff yeah I didn't send a private
investigator to your house I just did a
little bit of public information like
let me let me bring facts about your
parents dude well you knew you were
coming to talk to me for weeks okay I've
only done that you're welcome
talking about the issues not like my
face
we didn't talk about your family family
yeah I mean you were even applying
earlier first of all it is relevant that
your mom is the president when you're
talking about you did it you didn't know
any of the backlash I got well who cares
you said it just own it I'm asking you
didn't know any of the backlinks I did
not I didn't know about it no idea even
though you got that from a video that my
ex co-host made about me
um
right right let's see like this is
dishonest but what's the problem you're
getting backlash for for something that
you think so you're like you're not that
you brought your parents up when you're
talking about hiring people didn't you
I I said
I just I think it's a bit just you talk
about your parents all the time you talk
about how your dad is Rich you did a
tour of this whole barn with the bowling
alley in [__] recreational stuff in
it like why am I not allowed you
just said that you knew
from you got the clip from an it like
okay we're not here to protect your
reputation yeah I mean who cares I
didn't know about it to the extent that
it was such an issue for you but let's
just say it was I mean I do I do I do
have to go though because I have a show
coming up so
okay let's just end on this note
slavery was embellished because some
Masters had good relationships with
their masters some slaves had good
relationships all right all right but
don't you see how easy it is to just say
I don't think it was embellished
yeah
I don't think it's a secret that some
Masters had good relationships with
their slaves I don't think that's a
secret there's been a whole diverse
okay I really appreciate you having me
on um but I'm gonna go thank you
okay I appreciate you okay
have a good night uh she hung up
why you can't
she's panicking at the end there holy
[__] okay first of all I genuinely did
not know that it was such a sore point
for her I mean it is a crazy thing to
say I mean she gets backlash all the
time for all the things that she says
why is that one such so off limits
that I don't know I mean I can guess
because it's [__] insane but but like
just I mean yeah that's it but I'm gonna
uh I'm gonna let the children out of uh
you know I I tried to nail her down on
things as I do here but ultimately
chat you're free dude I've been
wondering what the [__] that noise is
the whole time I could not pay attention
because I just heard crunching there's a
lot oh what the [__] when the [__] did
you get here well have you been here the
whole time who let this idiot in who let
him in
how'd you get past security who gave him
food that's our snacks bro that's
budgeted in
take those away from him Ian why are you
letting me eat your snacks I told him to
stop and he said Ethan doesn't need
these stop what
I've lost a lot of weight [__] piece
of [__]
stop let's see who's fatter now
all right why are you here did you just
get back from Siberia or whatever the
[__] you cheaply record [__] cause
you're broke
would you say
I can't hear you back here bro
does someone have headphones for me or
something
you can't hear him he's like 10 feet
away
[Music]
what'd you say give him the [__]
headphones
Jesus Christ get out of here Amy why are
you even here dude what I was in the
neighborhood I stopped by and get some
snacks
some snacks what everybody knows you
guys got the best snacks here I mean
everybody does know that but I don't
know we do have really good snacks
what'd you say I don't know man just
listen dude you're supposed to listen
when I talk people well I don't know
it's hard when I'm eating I was saying
what did you just get back from Siberia
where like Trump Serbia dude right
Serbia
ever heard of it so what do you what do
you do there you just pay people no
money to do your dumb jobs I was making
epic music videos bro why do you go to
Serbia you ever seen the buildings in
Serbia
what about them you're [__] crazy
dude
nothing like it anywhere all those
architecture do you believe in slavery
was embellished
[Music]
definitely not thank you see how easy
that is that was so easy it's so easy
how do you how can you possibly say
slavery was embellished I mean sorry I
didn't get to I didn't get to debrief
Oliver from the conversation we had
these buildings are [__] okay that is
wait what the [__]
why is Serbia
who's building those
I don't know your problem maybe can you
chop stop chewing in the mic I'm not
chewing the mic is it this is my problem
is you're two-faced bro what yeah he
didn't stutter you heard what he said no
I didn't hear it I was chewing all right
pretended to support me from my fight
and then went and supported my opponent
what I'm friends with Dad what's that
have to do with anything oh he did a dad
video yeah
forgot about that betrayal
Ethan I can't hear you from back here
can I come sit up there I set up
headphones for you I prefer you don't is
there room for me no
all right
yeah Ian says I can come up dude he just
invited me there's no the mic doesn't
work and the seat's broken
Ian what do you think
yeah he's saying there's probably room
up there I don't think so there's
trailers you guys have any more of those
uh this mic doesn't work right Zach this
one's broken uh unfortunately it does
not work yeah it doesn't turn on
the clown show
love this song what's that psych [__]
[Music]
dude it's actually your your clown
outfit's really suiting the music thank
you man how you doing
I'm doing good that one not as good now
okay looks like you're having fun out
there yeah
so do you think George Washington was
homies with all his slaves I highly
doubt that yeah I highly doubt that
what's going on here
sorry to kill the vibe looks like you
guys are having fun over here well I
wanted to debrief a little bit from that
conversation do you mind if I do that
with you here
yeah are you not in a hurry are you well
I'm pretty much yeah I'm running late
for another interview go ahead leave all
right
[Music]
go do that
well I've been waiting for like six
hours so I'll sit this out let's hear it
you know it's funny how that last part
tripped her up so bad it's just I've
never even heard that take that slavery
was embellished it's so well documented
it's so well accounted for it's so well
understood it's literally the owning of
human beings that they were allowed to
be [__] killed raped sold separated
from their families George Washington
you literally as
to punish his runaway slaves he would
recapture them and sell them off to the
West Indies which is effectively of
death sentence in severe conditions
where the enslaves were subjective to he
would sell them off to the West Indies
company
like how is that embellished because
because Roots is a myth
but surely he meant mythology right when
he says myth I don't even know if he
said that Roots was a myth like what
does that even mean
roots oh there was some whole
controversy that because the the dude
who wrote it
um said it was from research from his
own family but then some people found
there were some inconsistencies
who gave you that pretty sure that's
what they're talking about is pickle
juice what the hell is this
I love pickle juice oh you want a Bobby
I could go for a Bobby can we get some
Bubbies I have some of this try that
wait you brought this yeah what the [__]
that's what your team's giving me
pickles good job you guys that is
actually pickle juice and I love pickle
juice
oh man it's so good
how we doing
can I get can we get some Bubbies out
here and more pickle juice bring it over
we'll bring out the Bubbies so because
this guy didn't base roots on a true
story then slavery is embellished
I think it's more complicated than that
it's not like he made it up but like
well he cares we know that it's real
right yeah exactly we know I mean
obviously people were enslaved so
I mean just see what was happening in
the 1950s they were just hanging black
people like
in that embellished yeah she's from what
state is she from
uh Illinois
suburb of Chicago right yeah yeah she
she's from an obscenely Rich family
and they're also the what
which again she was like trying to make
it sound like we like hired a pi to
follow her or something I literally just
Google her name parents and they're like
they're prominent figures
they're Bakers
no I said they're prominent figures yeah
and she talks about them all the time
anyway we've been talking about that
later
so what do you want are you here to
promote something where are you here no
not at all I'm just in a neighborhood
and I come by and get some snacks what's
with the new look
some stuff I've been designing
looks great dude you gonna sell that
kind of hype
I designed it myself I've been designing
been kind of living overseas
so I haven't really been around much how
you been
I'm feeling fine getting sued I got kids
you know the usual stuff how am I God
children doing
same two
Michael and Bruce
Jesus man
what
you want some no
what's new you like the pickles
the pickles are all right I'm more into
the juice
what do you keep asking me what's new
how many times I need to answer what's
new nothing
nothing's new
what feels same shitty little show
what's new with you you're in Serbia
doing videos and [__] now you're back no
I'm back briefly I'm about to go to
Croatia
seriously why you keep going all these
countries like that I love it ma'am I've
been chilling out hiding out I'm kind of
uh
laying low from the IRS
oh [__] I see yeah you know the deal
thank you
I was in Brazil for a while crazy out
there Rio de Janeiro
diet rest they'll get you no well I
don't technically live anywhere so it's
hard to track me down kind of Off the
Grid right now
Plus what's the age of consent in Brazil
all right
you would like to know you freaking
pervert I'm just trying to investigate
the reason you're there
hey check out some of the architecture
in Croatia I know that's why I'm going
scope outside I know you were such a big
uh ARCA head you know bro I've been
getting super into it yeah but yeah
mainly right now brutalist style really
into the concrete stuff yeah the
brewless stuff yeah I was just in
Hungary Budapest crazy crazy building is
that like did you skin PewDiePie's
gaming chair what is going on here with
your what are you talking about I
designed this myself really because that
PewDiePie put this [__] on a chair like
10 years ago who's Beauty bye
good one I'm sure
but yeah just been chilling basically uh
heading to Colorado tomorrow about to
play this uh show Red Rocks oh for real
that's cool how many tickets how many
people are there 9 000 you still got a
couple last tickets left but is that
festival or just you
it's me headline show I got this guy
nine thousand nine thousand wow good for
you bro good yep it's me Tiber days uh
upsol and then Little Ricky and also
super secret crazy ass group super
computer
opening up so got a pretty special
little thing going on there and uh yeah
I've been working on the show for like
five years that's part of what I've been
uh
is there hair in the pickle juice
no um
especially like a mixture like a movie
TV show
uh concert and Broadway play so it's
kind of like the future of Art in my
opinion but yeah it's just [__] been
bleeding out but can you stop with the
little uh I like the sound but I'm
trying to talk right now I also did a
video with Eric who called me ugly
well he was yeah he's right about that
okay look at us we're both pretty ugly
okay I'm fine I'll call you nothing
wrong with being ugly man ugly it's
beautiful that [__] I am technically
speaking I did a BMI a body mass
indexing I'm 33 so technically obese yo
you have more body I'm not doing that
again you're more value mastered me I
just went to the doctor mine's like 30.
I'm not touching you you lost that
opportunity you've been getting slim I
like it looks sharp I like it you look
great you're a 33 BMI well 34 probably
by now after all these pickles pickles
of zero calories
well I think it's yeah I don't know but
yeah been enjoying life you know trying
to have fun but yeah I've been working
on the show and basically
I invested four and a half million
dollars into this concert so I'm so
excited yeah well is it a tour or just
this one just one show it's my last show
ever oh right one of those
I'm serious is the only store I'm doing
uh it's a single can you move into frame
[__] am I out of frame yeah the preview
mode you're like as far away as you can
possibly be is that better it's not
better that's the opposite direction of
what we need you to do why don't you say
uh
uh dude these something in these pickles
you should try the juice no
you ruined that whole jar by the way
it doesn't matter because I'm about to
finish them I'm gonna kill him
was I was that a bad faith interview
with pearl absolutely not there was so
much more you could have said especially
on the points of her talking about uh
people being lazy when she comes from a
wealthy family you were very being very
nice about that I think if you really
wanted to just embarrass her I feel like
you could have on multiple occasions
I wanted to hear your thoughts on the
Jews I know she got some huh yeah and
not to mention on that last Point
there's a lot more stuff you could have
talked about with the whole Nick Fuentes
situation I didn't even ask about Nick
Fuentes because I knew that was like
whatever dead horse for her whatever
but
I mean I just showed her stuff she said
and asked her to justify it the thing I
noticed about her when watching a lot of
her videos that I tried to nail her down
on is like she says a lot of stuff like
I feel this to be true and nobody ever
challenges her on it you know and her
basically her whole [__] platform is
built on I feel this to be true
but ultimately I do think she is like we
use the word grifter a lot I do believe
she is in the sense that
broke can you [__] what dude AB
brought it take this please give me that
back don't [__] up bring your own
pickles [__] baby don't you dare
bro there's still two good ones in there
throw it out don't throw it in the food
prep blender
or the
terrain whatever the [__] I think she's
actually a grifter like in the true
sense in that
the one thing she always talks about is
like how life is not fair for men dating
isn't fair for men she literally just
Echoes stuff that like fresh and fit and
Andrew Tate say because she's like a
token woman
um
she is gives credibility to their
arguments because like see here's a
woman that believes that too are you
throwing [__] on my floor no the dogs
are here my dog has where are the
problems can we bring the dogs out no
they're not here right now but my dog
comes and he has kidney problems he eats
your [__] fish I said they're here I
want to see him
do you not care about the pickles stem
dude I didn't do anything you threw a
pickle stuff I didn't do [__]
can we get Swami in here please with his
uh you saw me here
yeah he's coming to kill you he shoots
the kill
I like that guy
um
yeah so I think she's just literally a
token like her her commitment to hating
women and like excusing men is
phenomenal and she's made a nice little
career out of it I think her her moment
is fading
but uh I see her all the time on like
Tick Tock and highlights and YouTubes of
her just saying like the most obscene
[__] and of course
it has no backing it's on the thinnest
pretense it's on no pretense
and you know when I bring these people
on they
they really can't support their
positions and they end up just leaving
uh
they just end up leaving and uh
frustration yeah and she shows no mercy
when it comes to other people like
telling a girl that she's on
antidepressants because she's on only
face she's nasty like yeah she holds no
punches so I don't I thought it was
pretty ironic how she was like this
isn't fair that you're asking me to rate
myself I was like
oh really right because you do that
every [__] day
dude what is wrong that's like I thought
that was like Oliver he's like belching
over there it's like half water in there
I don't know how the [__] you're doing
today that is pickles you don't look
well he's not well he hasn't been well
um all right so what do you so when's
some [__] coming out you want you want
people to buy tickets what do you want
people
um let's see what's going on just plug
whatever so you can use what's new uh
well playing the show uh June 20th at
Red Rocks it's probably gonna be the
future blueprint of the future of
concerts and movies it's basically this
new template I think it's about and
another thing Ethan is you could have
brought up so much more about like I'm
in the middle of [__] talking June
20th yeah no I just remembered like but
she had like some bad text about therapy
too yeah you could have definitely
brought those up you know and you you
have a I think you know experience so
you would be right to talk about it but
uh yeah I mean there's so much more we
could have said
yeah she's she's pretty vile yeah but
again I felt the interview was fair
and if she thought that question was
like gonna get her in trouble just say
that slavery wasn't embellished yeah but
she I guess Nick Fuentes is watching
like that's it that's who she was
texting with I loved it that clip it
pans over to Nick Fuentes agreeing he's
like she gets it she gets it
yeah uh here let me pull that up again
because I thought it was just so funny
um Oliver somebody uh DM me said they're
gonna be at your show really who's that
Nick Fuentes
that is
Pearl and Nick are coming just a random
just a random fan of ours really
remember [__] you guys got fans here can
they refund that or not yet oh there's
no reason no refunds on the tickets I'm
sorry but yeah it's gonna be epic Ethan
you think maybe you and the crew can
take your little vacay out there so
where is Red did you guys do your trip
to Japan or where'd you guys go Legoland
from we're going to Bahamas in Bahamas
we are going to the Bahamas yeah so
maybe we can start this trip Early Head
to Red Rocks Red Rocks Colorado it's
like the greatest outside Amphitheater
I've actually always wanted to go it's
basically cool that you're playing Red
Rocks like the Grand Canyon dude I would
love for you guys to be there and I got
free tickets for every single person in
this crew right yeah we've heard that
before yeah I gave you guys tickets
before Ethan always just comes up with
some kind of uh oh this is fire actually
[__] check this out that looks super
cool yeah the guys who did South Park
they just did a show here a little
concert of their Hometown but yeah I'm
pumped man oh that's beautiful give me 9
000 of the most die-harded it's probably
couple H3 fans maybe sprinkled in there
you know there's probably 90 nobody goes
to your show that'll probably be what it
looks like yes
but yeah there's gonna be some Teddy
fresh in that audience there always is
they'll probably have some signs you
know [__] Ethan Klein [__] h3h they try
to get me to chant that usually right
and we do we tend to oh this is actually
that is insanely beautiful I know I wish
you could be there man I wish all of you
could be there uh we actually have a
live show uh next week as well
I wish I could make it when is it 23rd
saw you had an Alex party little flyer
that dude's a legend oh yeah Alice party
did our art isn't that dope he's amazing
thank you for saying that I used to be a
big fan of him when I was really young
and I had him I went to have him sign
one of my Alex party shirts
he's a great guy he's a fan of the show
he I have a bunch of his original art
too not a bunch too three two oh it's
nothing I've got like five or six Bunch
you want to see the painting I got I
really like it yep
I want to see it
check this out this is in my living room
holy crap it's massive too that looks
crazy oh yeah
so sick that is wild my favorite uh
piece of art that I bought that's epic
thanks so are you here on the 23rd we
were wondering no I'm gonna be I'm going
to Croatia right after my little show on
red rocks in the 20th can you stop with
the little honking
but yeah besides that you know I got um
new music video that I filmed in Serbia
coming out on the 20th as well so it's
going to be a big day kind of show I'm
gonna play some unreleased music at the
show basically I made it into this whole
feature film though it's two hours long
so I've been busted that reminds me
Ethan I can't believe how much Bruce is
walking now he came in here yesterday
hold on hold on here is what really
happened
[Laughter]
so he wasn't as bad people are smiling
yeah Bruce is he's been walking for a
while he's he's slick man he's he's
starting to talk I'm calling him the
boss baby from now on I heard I heard
you guys were calling him he's boss baby
because he looks just like that so he
was funny he was walking around the
studio he was looking at me I'm like I'm
just looking at baby isn't he so cute
yeah
he goes like this like he's oh he loves
clapping you can just learn to clap yeah
he's so sweet oh he's so agile he didn't
fall one time he's fearless and it's
[__] up
okay well um
yeah you wanna what were you talking
about go ahead Ian with the to make it
more watchable thing
what's going on no you were talking
about your concert Serbia whatever
Serbia yeah just do your plugs Croatia
yeah I actually have this new company I
think is going to give Teddy fresh a run
for their money really yeah it's my new
clothing line wait what is going on here
dude can you please remove that off the
screen
it's just our viewers are very uh
they're very like 80d they have a hard
time focusing on the show so it's
helpful I'm doing move that right now
listen if that wasn't on there nobody
everyone would have clicked move it
right now Ethan this isn't [__] cool
just stop bro
[Music]
no no you showed up pull that off right
now take this off
that's helping me people watch man
that's better can we move it over to uh
the ride a little bit all right are you
done do you want to plug anything else I
mean um yeah just been having a good
life man hey what's going on here don't
remove me off the [__] screen dude
it's [__] [__]
[Music]
hold on we're having a technical issue
oh we got a technical issue can y'all
fix that or is that like a technical
issue it's a technical issue okay hold
on just a little technical issue here we
have some technical issue it sounds like
we do about it what are we gonna do
[Music]
what's up stop what I'm not doing [__]
dude don't do that do that don't do that
I didn't do anything Oliver's slamming
the button and holding it down no I
didn't do anything you started being
disrespectful to me on the podcast when
you invited me here as a guest I'd like
to do to every other guest you just come
on here and you stop with the sound
I did not invite you on
and your little buddies over there Ethan
Dan whoever
um
show me proof that I invited how am I
here right now if you didn't invite you
showed up in the building you [__]
show it up you don't know the door codes
changed since you gave them to me last
year okay so how explain that riddle me
that you know what [__] you dude because
you ruined my you ruined my [__]
Thanos snap joke by hitting that [__]
button man it didn't make the cut no you
stay the [__] ass between me and Ethan
do you want to tell it again yeah so
well it does it doesn't work the same
Ian can you cover him can you cover him
again so I could say it again
and you come and disrespect me on your
[__] just chill dude
[Music]
you cuts the whole thing don't you
understand you literally just cut the
whole thing
and the bit doesn't work if you come and
push the button Oliver
they didn't see any of that now
you should care
that whole fight sequence was cut
thanks genius
idiot bro loser Oliver was attacking me
he was getting physical
I had to respond in force and Oliver
pushed the button which unfortunately
erased the evidence of this crime but we
do have it on backup and we I will be
filing a police report is he still in
the office
yeah he is he's over there love can you
escort him out please yeah I'm on it
can we get a shot of Love escorting him
out
dude this is always the problem every
time he comes here he takes [__] too far
he gets too emotional you started being
violent why do you get physical that's
not what I'm about dude why do you force
me to beat your ass like I don't want to
do that
yeah you cut it out
what's the point of even coming here if
you're just going to hit the button like
a [__]
okay well it's on video we have the
backup video dumbass I am filing a
police report and I have many witnesses
idiot [__] dumbass
yeah anybody who's going to that dumbass
show
chargeback if you can't get a refund
charge back
okay
contact the venue though what's the name
of the venue again
can I get a refund on my ticket
at Red Rocks
okay so according to this
um
they have insurance
can I cancel a refund my ticket
has been canceled
yeah you can get refunds you guys
is he escort thank you
[Music]
love escort him out please
they can't hear but love escort them out
please Oliver's being a pain in the ass
he's trying to fight a [__] robot
[__] yeah he's literally trying to
fight me right now
dumbass just bro why are you still here
I want you to leave this is my property
I'm asking you to leave
I'm asking you to leave please leave
please leave
please leave please leave leave
call the police someone call the police
why do you take [__] too far bro I don't
want the police involved here
escort him out love and make sure he
leaves
tell me when he's outside the gate yeah
it's [__] [__] dude so [__] up why
is he always got to get physical man
[Music]
uh how to get a refund do you know what
ticket
um
agency they're doing at the Red Rock
thing
I believe it's access it's access okay
how to get a refund from access
wait access is that a real thing access
hey how's it a x s
o a x s got it so here here's how we
cancel our refund tickets
uh this is important for anyone who
bought tickets to a show
oh [__] it says all sales are final
okay so what you need to do is call your
bank and say it was fraudulent
or if you purchase on a credit card you
can you know discharge back yeah that's
basically the same thing yeah is he gone
he's gone yeah he's off
do you know how we got in
I legitimately don't like
that we have security doors where you
have to like have a passcode to get in
or whatever I don't
I might have to like ask around teddy
fresh if somebody opens we can check the
access history we can check the logs
yeah that's true that's true
maybe it was like someone was just out
there and
he just kind of snuck in yeah it's like
an apartment thing all of somebody else
and we got to be more careful about it
uh I just checked that the lock is
actually off our roof so he somehow got
he came in through the roof yeah and
climbed down the ladder
what the [__] such a [__] he kept
hitting the button
yeah and then he I don't think he
understands what he's doing I don't
think he understands at all [__]
dumbass dude
I don't think he understands at all
right
[Music]
thanks I guess oh we just got a uh 100
Super Chat Rachel Harris said yeah from
the uh
sending some love y'all played my game
Cameo the other day Gabe I think it's
just oh game shout out to my bestie
Teddy for getting it for me make me feel
better you guys always make me laugh I'm
a mortician Apprentice yo that's a
gnarly job and I listened to the show to
relax
she the one whose dog died or something
oh that one oh is it that one well
Rachel I'm sorry it's about
I don't even want to say it so
that's rough sorry about your mom
disowning you for being queer that yeah
it is horrible that's rough and I mean
genuinely though like leaving a pickle
stem on the floor here
oh come on
it's not cool
how much salt is in this thing like like
Shredder cannot cannot eat that
does even watch the show does he know
anything about Shredder
probably not
[__] idiot [__] dumbass yo [__]
idiot I hate that guy
[__] he won't even come to our show and
he goes oh please come to my show please
come to my show it's like [__] what
have you ever done for me
fake friends
also it's outside kinda kind of poor I
think no roof what if it rains dude
true where's the roof dumbass yeah
where's the roof I only go to venues
with roofs [__] me too oh there's
Andrew Tate news people are saying he
was officially charged
that's fire so I saw something just the
other day about the charges being
upgraded that he was being investigated
for like serial sex trafficking instead
of
I was confused by it was like apparently
before he was being investigated for a
series of individual
sex trafficking cases and now they
upgraded it to him being like a Serial
sex trafficker but that was like two
days ago so let me see if there's like
what happened how's that yeah no you did
you did a lot of sex trafficking as
opposed to just a little bit yeah here
we go uh Andrew Tate served with legal
letter of claim alleging sexual assault
and physical abuse wait so this is this
maybe something a new charge
he's [__] oh wait these are charges in
the UK
oh the UK do they have extradition with
um Romania Romania
is there it's all in Europe right yeah
probably well Britain did leave the EU
right right so maybe not but they
probably have an extradition agreement
with Europe you people are not I would
imagine Google it I I don't know yeah yo
UK charges on top G yeah four women in
the UK are now United to prepare legal
action against Andrew wait so this
sounds like maybe it's a lawsuit not uh
criminal charges just based off of that
does sound like it yeah legal firm uh
with a legal letter of claim at his
Bucharest residence while he's serving
house arrest pending charges of human
trafficking wow thank you this is all
coming down for old tady boy so anyway
let's talk about the
the Pearly thing I just find it so
interesting like clearly she knows who I
am and the conversations I've had with
people
I don't understand why these people
don't come at least a little prepared
that's a very good question I actually I
genuinely
um thought that she would be more
prepared
like she
from the content that we've watched of
hers uh she's always throwing out stats
and everything it's all made up I don't
want to say it's all made up but I think
a lot of it is misinterpreted a lot of
it is exaggerated well she has a
repertoire she has like a dialogue tree
that she sticks to yeah and I mean for
instance there was like the dating app
thing and she made a claim we tried to
find the source of that claim we found a
similar claim that was kind of saying
the same thing and presented that to her
and she didn't
really refute that it seemed like even
she wasn't sure if we were talking about
the same study it just it seems like
this is
a lot of her opinions are based on vibes
that's that was one of my art High
arching themes you know also the wage
Gap thing she straight up was like it's
three percent I was like okay great
also a lot of them are yeah a lot of her
opinions go against her own best
interest like the the way that she said
women are all emotional that's literally
like they're all emotional then she goes
Ethan let's argue and so you rightfully
will be like well that what you just
said is arguing from emotion pointing
out the irony and also the fact that she
was and she would just be like why would
you even say that and then she'll be
like 21 is way better than 26. I'm 26 by
the way
she has nothing to stand on that's
something we didn't get into my takeaway
from the last two days of looking into
her
I I don't know this for sure and I know
you didn't necessarily agree with me
Ethan but I I think it's all fake I
think it's a put on I don't think she
really I think she's cynically is just
leaning into it for
to uh to get traction on the internet
and has been very successful on it
it's just like because when you started
drilling down on some of those things
like you said the gender gap the wage
Gap thing it's like she makes these
definitive statements it's a myth and
then you ask her about it almost
immediately she admits that it exists
it's just not a big deal so why do you
say it's a myth it's not a myth right
percent is a lot who wants to make three
percent less over their lifetime right
which again just to me screams grifter I
don't know yeah her ex-best friend made
a video that went pretty viral and she
was like I had 22 years of Friendship
with this girl and not once did she ever
have beliefs like these I saw that stuff
and of course I didn't bring it up
because again I wanted to argue in good
faith right it's like let's just talk
about stuff she said yeah and for
example slavery was embellished yeah for
example yeah
yeah pretty interesting I don't know I
thought you made a pretty good point
when she said um
a lot of people in the chat asking if
they're saying they thought she was like
high or something I don't think so no I
thought it was crazy she did seem a
little out of it but I think it was more
just she was very nervous maybe yeah I
thought right out the gate when she like
dropped her first hot take and she was
just like divorce should be banned I was
like is she serious right now what is
happening it just seems like I'm just
gonna say this extreme thing because I
know it's gonna get a rise out of people
100 when I was prepared to ask her about
those kind of statements I was expecting
her to kind of walk them back and be
like that's just a joke I don't really
believe that right but she goes no
divorce should be totally illegal but
then when you prod just a tiny bit she
goes okay finally fine there's some
exceptions but why do we have to focus
on the exceptions it's like what the
[__] are you talking about
the exceptions matter
they matter a lot that's kind of like
why
There are rules to [__]
so it's fair for everybody
yeah and like the other big one that
jumps out to me is like I don't think
women should have the right to vote
do you really believe that I really like
I know she insists that she does but
it's like it goes nowhere though I say
okay
why they didn't they don't sign up for
Selective Service do you think women
should serve in the military no also who
says she's competent enough as a woman
to make that judgment
she's clear she's not I'll tell you why
because she's single as [__] and by her
own logic she sucks because first of all
why is she giving women advice when her
ass is single by the own logic she's a
low value woman she should she shouldn't
be giving anyone advice and also when
she's talking about virginity and she's
like I'm not
like
what are you preaching for like why are
you telling girls to be virgins if
you're like I did I not me though I
thought what men want she doesn't want
virgin she brings men on her show I
never saw one single reasonable guy it's
all like fresh and fit
dating red pill guys who are like uh if
my if I had a if I was in love with a
woman with 20 bodies I wouldn't marry
her it's like are you [__] nobody I'm
in love with her but I wouldn't I
wouldn't allow myself to be happy
because
I'm sorry statistic
men do not in general I don't care I
don't and by the way it's like
you can logically think through it and
think one is not fair it's hypocritical
to say it doesn't matter for men body
count but it matters for women and
she'll bypass all that by saying no no I
don't care about what's right or wrong
it's just about what men want it's like
men don't want that
I genuinely think that men don't care I
don't know yeah it sounded like
everything was
probably based in a self-hatred type oh
my God oh God why is that Oliver
what is happening
oh my god dude what did you do
ela's here
oh [__] seriously stop am I gonna heal
it you're hurting him you're hurting me
stop seriously I didn't do anything why
are you bringing him here man stop
stop I didn't do [__] bro stop
get them off maybe take him out please
choke them out choke them out bro choke
them out
[Music]
do something yeah I do kinda
[Applause]
nice
all right can you leave please
call the [__] police call the fire
marshal I don't care why are you guys
not calling the police why is he back
why is he wearing the pope jacket
[Music]
I started stealing stuff he stole the
jacket
and then he stole some sweaters
and he ran out of the office into the
street he did
he really did
and he he was hiding behind a car
we need pictures of him like don't let
this man in he was in here he got
physical with me
yeah
I don't know what to say so of course
taken care of let me let me be the point
Pearl a woman in a relationship with him
can't get a divorce
nice yeah that's [__] up did you watch
any of that I watched like the beginning
at 30 minutes and the last 30 minutes I
think oh you saw the last three minutes
were good
with these the slavery was exaggerated
oh [__] I didn't see that
yeah because I wanted to watch it again
anyway is he gone Lena
I sure hope so God damn
wait did we get the puffer back before
we left
yeah I don't even know where my camera
is at right now dude thank you uh a b
yeah we appreciate it I was listening uh
when she was talking about pregnancy and
I was like [__]
did you carry a baby and tell me how how
was that for you yeah right
yeah she's not married she's single I'm
having babies anytime soon she's single
as [__] it's like
no her whole energy is just giving me
like she's just trying to get laid with
some guys she thinks she's like being
the cool girl pick me girl slash grifter
all coming together yeah here check out
this tape and she goes I didn't say that
I was quoting a book tell me what you
think by the way Nick Fuentes is sitting
next door nodding like yeah sounds
similar to the slavery stuff too because
that's that's literally they they the
defender of or the
said I wanted for my people to live by
so they often but that's what they do is
they embellish and I'm not trying to say
it wasn't horrible it was right but they
want to make it like more horrible so
that they can control people
wow pretty wild eh and she took it back
no she wouldn't even say I was like do
you think slavery was embellished and
she wouldn't answer
I was like just say no it's a layup for
almost everybody in the world right
she's like I feel like you're doing a
gotcha I was like like you said it did
the Holocaust happen I mean there's only
one answer that I should ask that should
have been the next one should I should
have asked yeah
but okay there she goes oh yeah so she
was saying women shouldn't have the
right to vote because you did wait I
didn't hear that part oh yeah she says I
just heard when it was frustrating me
when she kept saying that women have all
the choices when it comes to pregnancy
and it's like well [__] if the guy could
be pregnant I'd choose that you know if
I had all the choices it was all up to
me well also what is she saying that a
man can choose to terminate the baby and
someone woman's body like are you that's
not like no she's the opposite she wants
you to keep the baby against your will
exactly right right and that didn't say
that
having gone through two pregnancies that
I cannot imagine going through that I
guess your will that is just Insanity
it's barbaric
so
um
it's my body I'll do whatever the [__] I
don't know
and there it is
always right did you ask Pearl before
you uh got that abortion did you was
there someone you forgot to ask well and
the thing is is her stance is so extreme
that like I thought it was good how you
Ethan even granted her the pro-life
position yeah like let's just accept
yeah let's just let's just go with it
that that abortion is murder and that's
a life and it shouldn't happen or
whatever oh God I put the pickle juice
in my [__] soda
God damn it dude he's not even here and
he's ruining my day sorry Dan go ahead
right and the thing is even when you
give her that much of the benefit of the
doubt you can still tackle her argument
because yeah like the medical exception
thing when it endangers the life of the
mother and the baby yeah and she goes
through cases of insects she reads I
think that somebody sent her and I was
like that was so stupid what about
they're like oh well according to this
doctors recommend abortion because they
know it's going to endanger your life
yeah but she completely read the whole
thing wrong because she thought it was
saying the number was exaggerated and it
was talking about like she was like yeah
they say it's inflated but they say it's
inflating you were like thank you
I would say it was maybe Rolo Tony Brown
town but um didn't we learn that Rolo
Tony hates her oh he blocked her yeah
pull up that twist yeah that tweet is so
she put [__] funny she's like this is
the saddest thing I've ever seen in my
life she can't even get roller Tony to
like her
birthday and he wants the man to like
her yes and she's single her life
doesn't work by her own existence if her
advice was good she wouldn't be single
she'd be pregnant and married
here it is here it is okay one second uh
hold on one sec hold on to that Olivia I
want to show this tweet this is the
saddest
uh
uh explanation for Pearl and it really
sums up her
her whole vibe Dan work did you get it
sorry I'm getting it from the WhatsApp
right now go ahead Olivia's oh
um yesterday while we were watching a
bunch of Clips I noticed that when she
had Andrew Tate in the studio she got
all gussied up she curled her hair she
was wearing a pretty dress yeah I
thought it was so
Rose oh my
oh my God that's crazy
Pearl was a little nervous she was a
little bashful yeah and I hope you can
see how she gets like a lot more um
embellished in the way she talks when
she goes off like women are just so
whiny like she thinks she's doing a bit
or something like she's
but it's like how do you can't argue
with that it's like she's got material
yeah I think she is straight up women be
lying women be shopping yeah here's the
tweet she said even though Rolo tomasi
blocked me and talked [__] about me
every day I still respect his work to no
end he's one of the best Minds in red
pill go watch Rolo's stream on church
YouTube the rational male Church it'll
come up changes your POV oh my God
uh
yeah so I don't know
uh uh by the way there it is just we are
posting these around the office right
now
um can you show them no yeah just so no
employees over at Teddy fresh or
anything you know think that he's
supposed to be here or something he's
not coming back right
I don't know yep as far as I know he's
left the premises is that right that's
what I thought do we have confirmations
freaking out they thought he took the
jacket with him
how'd you get those back you came back
breathing pretty heavy
I've been running around I think for 10
minutes straight
chased him down like yeah chased him
down he was at the corner
it's a [__] weirdo he's just running
like he doesn't have a car
he's just running yeah yeah he was
running in the spray with a jacket on a
pile of sweaters
a little [__] up what a what a weirdo
um all right I'll leave you guys to the
greatest show thank you
oh yes the the Lego uh the brick what's
his name brick Chef brick Chef yeah
um
the racism stuff but I will say I really
hard for her because
she definitely seems like super racist I
mean here she is talking about Nick
Fuentes I did not find Nick to be racist
um my staff actually did not find him to
be racist wait he was okay she says I
did not find Nick Fuentes to be racist
my staff did not find Nick Fuentes to be
racist uh here is
Nick Fuentes sitting right next to her
saying this look at this [__] I don't I
don't it's luck to racist oh I'm not
racist uh yes you are yes you are Nick
yeah I am a little bit racist but listen
but it's not because I hate people I
love people it's just race is real
race is real race is a part of us
so hey it is what it is and um the
Italians we do not claim you oh I said
this is this is the part that's
fantastic hey it is what it is and um
the Italians we do
maybe they don't claim you oh no they
claim me they claim me I don't think so
they do
Italian Guys yeah Italian Italian guy
about your affinity for black guys
that'll go over real well
good one Nick okay now let's go back
once again and see what she said about
Nick John the eagle thing's gone
I have a video coming out about that um
I did not find Nick
's done my staff actually did not find
him too her staff
did that woman look like she thought he
wasn't racist to you
maybe some Brazil
there's a Metallica I will make my uh
black boyfriend some of that ugh wow
you don't know any better
Jesus Christ
look he's like the human embodiment of
racism he even says it himself he's not
racist well everyone loved him
[Laughter]
so there it is hopefully I
was able to pin her down on some things
exposed that her convictions are about
as
thin as
ice
cold his eyes then as a film of
microwave that's on top of a glass of
microwaved milk
[Applause]
uh film on the top you don't know about
that yeah yeah
I know about that you look at me
um yeah so that's it is she Tweeting or
anything she's got to be not happy about
that
you have to imagine she was or is I
don't think it's a trap though my
goodness you know what's funny though
when I was looking through her Twitter
during the show I saw the quartering in
her have a beef and the quartering says
i s uh I deleted the invite for you to
come on my show I stand by everything I
said you fish for literal in cells with
insane takes each even even the ones you
don't believe
damn even the quarterings calling her a
grifter that's pretty bad your profit
from the continued status of men it's
your whole model well dude is anybody
like her Jeremy went woke the Freshman
fit guys do am I right I guess yeah I
guess maybe oh I saw yeah maybe I don't
know I doubt they like her let's be real
she should just be herself
I think she's too hard on herself Well
yeah if she thinks about if she thinks
about herself like she thinks about all
women then yeah right yeah totally she
rated herself a five that was like what
that really hurt me to see her rate
herself for five
well I mean at least she was high
distant I know what you're saying but
it's still it's just like
whatever systemically is happening to
where you're rating yourself as average
and or below
that's what needs to be addressed she's
straight up who wants to settle yeah
literally who wants to settle which
medium to low value man wants to come
settle on me
[__] up way to view the world man
that's insane
insane I mean the whole virgin thing too
it's just like I mean listen I I can
only speak for myself but it that is not
does anybody agree with me that that is
not a desirable trait like at all Middle
School
I feel like having I feel like having
sex with a virgin can be pretty like
it's not good yeah it's gonna be pretty
like
dramatic maybe or just stressful or yeah
it's not good yeah no and she said it
herself uh the only the only logical
conclusion to draw from that is rooted
in insecurity like you don't you're
afraid of being compared to some past
partner that was but I'm glad she said
that and then she's like yeah they're
insecure so what I was like
right so go to therapy yeah I guess at
least we found the middle ground on that
one and the way she like objectively
believes that all of this is true where
she was like Beauty literally like is
objective men only want 22 year olds to
be happy you have to have some sort of
delusion like Let Yourself believe that
that you're great and then maybe
everything else will be great
blue pill
yeah so I don't know what else to say
but men love MILFs
that completely she couldn't deal with
it men love MILFs as Martin said who
doesn't who doesn't love it
this this idea that every man is just
looking for a perfect 20 year old to
marry is so 20 year old virgin a dilf
that's so weird
who are you talking about
[Music]
deals
if if you're a guy looking for a virgin
you're [__] a sick twisted [__]
weirdo
and Society will judge you same with a
45 year old guy plus who's dating a 22
year old you will be judged for being a
weirdo because you are
and there it is and there it is thank
you guys how long we've been going for
we've been going for three hours and 15
minutes three hours three seconds are
you serious yes I'm serious holy [__]
that went by fast wrap it up so wait we
did talk to her for a fair bit of time I
guess uh by the way just did we mention
the uh huge drop of gifted subbies then
oh no go ahead let's talk about our our
Saudi benefactor once again hitting us
with is it 200 I believe it's 200.
memberships and that's a gift for you
guys ultimately that's so nice and I'm
so thankful thank you my friend I
appreciate it
and thank you to all of our members uh
we had a great
members live stream yesterday uh talking
about the one and only Colleen
Ballinger
and I didn't want to talk about it on
the main show so I talked about it there
although I had I heard some gossip that
and I'm not gonna say from where I heard
this
but
okay dude there I'm sorry but there's
some crazy ass tea coming out of this
here send this to me in Discord so I can
show this
I'm gonna send it and uh okay what are
you the Colleen [__] is is pretty wild
I'm gonna send it
so the tea that I heard
is that Trish is going to be making a
statement about Colleen soon
[Music]
how about that
it's in the Discord
um
here's the twi so this guy tweeting this
by the way this is Oliver tree
dumbass
yeah
uh here is a tweet that's going viral
this is one of these this is a guy who
was in one of her uh little
groups for kids
and so he's talking about this you a lot
of our viewers probably don't know what
you're referring to
uh Colleen Ballinger AKA Miranda sings I
think people know about it it's pretty
big she's being like utterly canceled
right now because uh of basically really
inappropriate relationships with kids
a history of it
and um
yeah there's a lot of people talking
about it and she just made a new podcast
with Trisha
and so this guy who was one of these
kids who was in one of these chat rooms
with her tweeted this [__] Colleen and
her friends subscribe to Trish's only
fans they would literally have little
viewing parties just to body shame and
make fun of her they would invite her to
their home and smile on her face while
doing this behind their back that's
[__] really sad
sorry girl but these are your friends
Trisha consider this info over shared
that's the name of their podcast
that's that's really sad I feel bad for
Trisha hearing that if that's true
that's really really really horrible I
do genuinely believe that's true based
on nothing
based on Vibes yeah Vibes is everything
what are you a woman
this moment
there was another uh clip that people
were sharing of don't come for me please
uh Colleen's thing
that Trish is a whale uh some I saw the
videos I was not talking about this
Ethan let's wrap it up it's been three
hours I'm defending Krishna I'm
pro-tricia in this case yeah
I changed my mind there's the music
uh I want to find that okay whatever I
did really want to talk about Boby
's alt is so [__] amazing bubble X's
all got leaked we could talk about on
Friday but it is amazing it's so crazy
stop dude it's so crazy
we thought about no I think this is
worth saying we thought about inviting
him on the live show before this alt
came out
why what's wrong with that
we wanted to do a gag where he was in
the uh
we're using the audience
but we changed our mind stop
why
but anyway his alt is very funny
uh Dan is yelling at me
so anyway
his alt got leaked and it's crazy
this is probably the worst alt leak I've
ever seen of anybody ever
it's so bad it's so bad like it couldn't
be worse
uh we'll talk about on Friday though
sounds good
I thought it'd be funny if he was in the
audience and went
heck or something you know
surprise cameo
it's not happening though
and that was before the all Revelation
super races
super duper races pre-altera
free all
PA p a yeah the aid era
all right politely delay I'm being
played off
thank you everybody it's been a treasure
it's been a treat I love every I want to
thank everybody at the Academy all my
friends I want to thank God
I'm gonna take my mom my dad for always
believing me I want to thank my wife Ela
for always believing me always standing
behind me I want to thank my beautiful
kids who
have always supported me and have always
believed in what I do I want to take my
crew who stood by me uh in in good and
bad times putting their heart and soul
into every episode I want to thank the
audience
who is Faithfully
stayed with us
[Music]
foreign